Oh,
okay.
Brian.
You like God damn.
Dj Mix master character recording.
No,
no.
Calm down.
Shit.
Stupid together.
Sign right there we go.
Making noises here.
Let's do this.
Yes.
Korea
[inaudible] early 90 [inaudible] wicked in this song.
Star of Shit is the,
he has wisdom.
[inaudible] pro black in any,
no chose commerce.
Wait Fun on the road.
Black and it ain't no joke.
Bitches.
How are we doing here Tom?
I tell folders.
Yeah,
it was good man.
Whatever happened to Paris following a path for no,
just went to Paris.
He's done.
We'll make progress.
Page scrolls a little.
They came with the master plan of God for no who's opposed to the dominant dog
skin food for phone as a loan for the brother.
Man,
I need to get a Paris tee shirt.
Where's the back of the county?
Maybe
just released a new album.
Looks like in 2009 Oh really though.
What a gift from Heaven Tempo One 16.7 keeps you locked in.
Somebody tell me as Paris on Twitter,
I'll,
I'll pile on.
Don't we find this man flag flagging go will be.
Perhaps the black with a rec Nigga.
What was,
what was once at much greater heights falsely?
When did Joey,
we'll put them on for with orange juice.
Jones are in.in the flux show right there.
Alright.
John Harrison,
somebody out who blah.
How many songs had orange juice?
Jones have gone.
That's
the one I didn't even have a whole slowly he would,
he would just open up then in Paris would take that thing off it up.
Yeah.
You'd have to have a little video for the audience.
How about a round of applause for the soldiers?
You know
of the weights Dab.
I bet around the Boswell,
the sex and ladies in the house.
There's a lot of black dudes like to do that in Iraq.
A lot of people like to do it.
People like to do that.
Give big rounds of applause.
Applause.
Where's all the potty?
People's drinking.
Who's got HIV?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Plus this motherfuck out.
Nice here the date please.
Thank you for being here.
Joe Rogan experienced flashlight as you fuckers know was sponsored by
fleshlight.
You don't need to fuck your hand.
Nobody can fuck a cup that has a heritage or whatever.
It's like,
it looks like a big gulp.
And I see the blue one and I finally watched pieces Avatar.
Now I knew what the blue one was four.
I didn't watch the whole lab with call yet.
But here it is.
That's a little asshole one.
You know what I'm saying?
I wonder if they're going to get away with this whole blue alien pussy thing.
People like,
I think they already did.
They got away with it.
How'd they get away with it?
Well,
it's just a blue alien.
You guys are the ones that are making references to have a toy.
But didn't they have like images on their site that looks like that was from
a,
a movie?
Uh,
porn parody.
Okay.
And then did they sell that porn parody with this?
No,
I don't.
I think that was just,
they,
they were in,
in conjunction with it.
Like,
you know,
they were,
I think there were so in it really,
I don't know,
maybe they were in conjunction,
but either way.
I mean it's certainly implied.
Oh,
I have no issue with it.
What do you think it should be accepted under the laws of parody?
You know,
if you can make a parody of something,
you should make a fake pussy or something too.
I had a double clip pussy as a goof parodies or,
yeah,
weird to me.
I don't understand how it works.
Like there is a bobble head recently that street that was Steve jobs bobblehead
and l only like 300 were made or something like that.
And they put a stop to it because it was a likeness of somebody,
you know?
And that was apparently it wasn't,
it didn't look exactly like,
I mean it was like a big head bobble head,
but I guess that was considered too much of a parody or something.
Using your likeness.
That's a weird,
weird line,
right?
You can goof on someone,
but if you're selling things when you're goofing on them,
like how,
what happens?
Like if you do like what if you were like a Jim Brewer and Jim Breuer did that
Joe Pesci impression,
right?
Remember we used to do that impression all the time,
And he started selling tee shirts,
let's said like Joe Pesci says go fuck yourself.
And it's him with that expression.
Yeah.
Are parodies though.
And they're making money off of it,
but yet you can't sell it.
Bobblehead that looks like Steve Jobs.
Well that was Steve jobs cause he's fee fucking jobs.
You got more money than God.
He shot him down.
Probably has more money than God.
Maybe they're just not.
Maybe they're seen Avatar as like a fake character that someone is constructed.
So it's,
you're allowed to have a parody of that.
Right.
And not have a guy who's not an entertainment.
Absolutely figure cause he's just a person.
But then how did they do like George Bush shit and like,
I don't know,
I think maybe it's public domain when you hit like a certain height,
like when you get to be like George Bush famous,
maybe you become public domain.
Maybe you could just sell Bush socks,
t shirts with his face on it.
I don't know.
How does that happen?
Do you think they do them and then they'd just get shut down like that?
Just the State Department comes after him to say stupid,
canceled George Bush tee shirts,
asshole.
Well,
close up shop.
The State Department won't say that to you.
What those motherfuckers would do is put an audit on your ass.
You know what I'm saying?
Did you hear about that fucking guy in I ran that went to jail for like,
I think it was six years because he made a movie about the corruption during the
elections.
It's fucking sad story man.
You know everybody complains about America now.
Fucked up America is all this wikileak Shit,
right?
Yeah.
It's fucked up.
But it's the best of the fucked up places.
You know,
you can make them freedom to make a movie about fucking bashing people here,
but in another countries that don't fly though.
Yeah,
they really doesn't fly then and lock this fucking guy out.
But that whole election,
Manny member,
all the riots that they were having,
I don't know the exact particulars,
but it was very clear to corona corruption,
corruption levels in those places.
It's just so mind boggling.
Go vote.
But the box is already stuck with ballots.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like that one.
It's so fucking corrupt,
you know,
so it's like these people live in hell.
Anyway.
So this guy that got put in jail,
he knew that there was going to be consequent.
He just thought he was fucking cute.
You gotta be careful though.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
he thought he was cute and he was trying to make a change.
But I don't know if that's how changes gets made.
I mean,
I guess it is,
man.
I mean it's,
it has to be the overwhelming.
We'll have the people to,
to bend back a corrupt government and it takes an incredible amount of effort to
bend back a really corrupt government.
The key is to never let it get to corrupt because people like all the laws are
in place.
I mean,
what,
what's really important about them is to keep shit from getting out of hand
because once she gets out of hand,
it can stay out of hand.
People get really used to anything and other people in Liberia,
it just like the people here,
they're just growing up in this fucking insane warzone chaos,
cannibal environment.
With fucking war lords and guns in little kid's hands and they're just shooting
people and you know,
they get used to that though,
man.
You get used to that and it's very difficult to turn that into this.
The key is to never let this become that because if it does become that,
then that becomes the norm.
It would take hundreds of years to turn library around.
Yes.
Disease.
You're not going to go on there,
whatever gene and just we're going to stop [inaudible] certainly not going to go
in there with boxes or rice and fix everything and you have to fix these people
as human beings.
You have to the,
the influence of all these people who have experienced murder,
I mean that,
that,
that's just through,
it permeates through the entire culture.
All these people have experienced horrific murders in their lives.
When you have a whole culture like that and you have this guy,
um,
general butt naked,
you ever heard of that?
That guy's story sounds from Liberia general buck naked used to take off all his
clothes and fucking fight naked and go shoot naked.
And he would find a,
a,
an innocent child of the enemy and then they would kill it and eat parts of its
body and drink.
It's blood.
What an asshole.
No bullshit.
Okay.
And this guy,
you know,
this guy was just running through,
these,
these countries or these,
these territories having these fucking horrific wars and they all saw this shit
and everybody's seen like terrible,
terrible things happen in Liberia.
And if you try to take that guy who tried to take any of those people and try to
turn them around and make them like a normal,
everyday person,
it's virtually impossible.
The guy shoots people fucking naked.
You know,
he's got a 12 it's Becky's black,
he's running down the street,
shooting other fucking people in.
And you know,
you can't,
I mean,
terrifying story.
He grew up in this different environment.
These people cannibals,
those people fucking Adam and they're used to it,
man.
And the,
this guy's become like a crusade Christian.
It's really kind of crazy cause he's still out,
you know.
I mean,
even though everyone,
Amy,
he admits to all these crimes and all the shit that he's done,
he's still just like kind of walking around and everybody's like,
Whoa,
shoot.
We like lock this guy up.
He eight babies.
Right.
And he's,
there's video of him talking about eating babies,
the cannibalism that's done,
they're like that.
That type of,
is the capitalism done for some of,
it's the hunger and the other part of this to kill the spirit so you can't get
that motherfucker.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that.
The whole Patois of it to just,
You just don't want to,
I'm going to kill Brian and he just fucking ear.
So he never did come back to getting the ever again.
That's part of it.
You know,
just going back,
he's an eel is motherfucker,
you know what I'm saying?
She shows a certain amount of,
yeah.
Ferocity,
you know,
certain amount of ferocity.
You want to kill someone and eat and eat them.
That's,
yeah.
I mean it's just,
I mean,
what they're doing is they're participating in the most ferocious war zone in
the world.
And in this war zone in Africa,
man did some of the,
the fucking civil rights violations,
some of the horrible things that happened there when you read about,
I think they called them the Hutus and the Tutsis.
They say this to these two warring tribes that have been at after each other
forever.
They participate in machete attacks where they go into villages while everyone's
asleep and they hack them to death with machetes.
I mean,
dude,
there's some crazy apocalyptic shit going down an African man and it's been
going down in 2000 fucking mother.
The problem is it's already happened.
It's too late.
It's like it's,
the culture is so fucked up.
Everything so crazy.
It's like,
how do you stop it from ever getting to that spot?
That's what we've got to make sure and every little fucking creep of corruption,
every little grip that we lose every little time that something fucking gets
away.
Every time did the corruption gets worse and worse.
We get closer to that.
That's,
that's the ultimate,
the ultimate end of the,
the,
the horrible,
you know,
attitudes and ideas of society is it eventually society degrades to some fucking
crazy,
mad max type situation.
You know?
And that's why that's such an appealing theme in movies because we know that,
you know,
everybody's just got to keep it together.
So that just doesn't happen because this is a real possibility.
Women taste them.
I dunno about Mad Max.
I seen that fucking movie with Denzel Washington of the,
I had button.
Oh Eli Bugatti,
the worst fucking greasy shit.
I watch 15 minutes of that Denzel,
you shot your low with man on fire.
Thank fucking God does that.
Whatever.
I don't even like those movies.
It don't make no sense to me.
Road Warrior was good.
I liked,
I could see fight for gas and stabbing motherfuckers on the one on one that I
don't mind killing somebody on the four oh five that cuts you off in a fucking
bad car and shit.
Get Brian to build me one of those helicopters and shit.
But that shit walking around and the baddest motherfucker with guns and knives
and they wouldn't do the,
it wasn't a blind too was I don't fucking need blind.
He was horrible with the swords.
Get fucking blade to go in there and teach how to stab that mother fucker.
Blame is a bad ass mother fucker when he was in there with the source,
by the way.
He's doing fine.
He's got you.
Was He in jail?
Yeah,
he's,
he had a report.
I believe he's in jail where they have many.
Anybody know where they have,
he got to pay your taxes,
ladies and gentlemen.
I don't give a fuck if you think it's a scam.
It seems like it is.
It seems like,
man,
this is the mom.
I'll get worked over what I have to pay 48% cause do all right.
Just throw in.
Everybody asked to throw in.
Yeah.
It's kind of corroborate.
We're not exactly sure where it all goes.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy that you don't get to vote on where your money goes,
but throw the fucking money and you crazy assholes.
40% is what keeps this from turning into APP.
Yes.
Always remember that.
That 48% and even then,
I mean people get hookers with it.
You know that Congress and they're getting their dick sucked them,
whatever.
But just put it behind you and pay your taxes because that sounds good.
Paper people don't concentrate on too is like as far as like government,
a big part of what government is providing jobs.
There's a lot of people that need jobs and if you're going to get that tax
money,
the best way to get that tax money is to make more government jobs,
make more an unnecessary jobs.
So you,
you give money to people now,
stuff about you better know about this Wesley Snipes.
Piss somebody off while he looks missed.
Somebody can't not pay your taxes for like seven years.
When you're a huge movie star,
you can't.
That's terrible.
It's what happens after that.
The government doesn't want to put you in jail when you make those type of
Dukkha,
but they do.
If you've taken a stance,
his some crazy,
fuck them.
Sorry.
He wrote something on the letter,
he pulled the suck this Dick.
That's what they did.
Yes he did.
He did he go after big time.
Do you know this happened or you just,
yes.
No,
this is a true story.
Suck my dick like something.
When he made,
he didn't think he had to pay to pull the load.
He may like in England or something.
Whoa.
It's something stupid.
I gotta pay it.
Listen,
listen,
let me tell you,
I didn't pay taxes for a,
after 91 I got divorced and I became a comic and that was my point was to become
a fucking outlaw.
So I didn't want to pay taxes.
Now with sketch shit,
I didn't pay taxes from 91 the 2004 I walked in that building
when you said that outlaw,
if we were on the ball,
we would have had so clinics,
movie sound playing in the back.
Oh No,
no,
you don't.
When you,
when I first read the Lenny Bruce Book and I liked that whole Patois,
to me it seemed like he disappeared.
He was a comic that disappeared and I liked that idea.
You just disappeared,
like used to say he's gone.
You don't know where he is.
We can't get ahold of him and I always liked that.
So I stopped paying taxes.
I wouldn't make any money those years.
I think it was one year I made money.
One of them,
one went down there.
The government was very nice to me.
They gave me a payment plan.
They took the 10 years.
I didn't pay him,
said don't worry about it all.
You got to go back and seven years and not till today.
I pay him monthly juice every month.
How much you owe?
I owed a after everything,
I think I got them for 8,000
I knew a lot of comics and had problems with taxes in Boston because in Boston
they got paid in cash,
so a lot of guys for years they just lived high on the hog and it never did
anything about it and they just figured out out they'll come get you on the door
eventually.
I know so many comments.
They always knock on the door when you win the lottery and they were making good
money.
There was a time I wasn't at that level,
but the,
the,
uh,
when,
when I was coming up like right as I was coming up,
when I was like,
just barely starting to get paid work,
the headliners in town could do it.
There's a next comedy stop.
They would do,
I swear to God,
they would do five shows at night,
man.
They would go from one room to the other room.
They had two rooms downstairs and one room upstairs and was shuffled people in
all night and the fucking shows would be packed.
And these guys were making crazy money and it was all cash.
They were all just raking in the cash and they just never put it aside.
They never fucking put those taxes aside.
They just spent what they had and they just,
you know,
just didn't do anything about it.
And then before,
you know what,
they were fucked,
you know,
they all hundred thousand dollars or something crazy.
Oh,
they send you a bill that said,
oh,
they said,
make your head go out in the fucking room.
You don't realize,
man,
are you make a reality you a hundred grand,
a hundred grand,
you know,
a few years in a row,
like a lot of these guys who are making you all,
lot of you a lot of money.
That's when you start working for yourself.
You really start noticing like what,
what taxes really are.
You're like,
wow,
what a giant chunk.
But if I would pay it willingly,
happily,
if I thought that we were all working in the right direction and then everybody
was trying to clean the world up and make people nicer and you know,
and stop all the Douche Dennis and you know,
and clean out all our fucked up laws and I'll pay it all,
fix the streets if you're doing the right thing with it,
I'd be more than happy to give up half my money.
I don't trust you fucking cunts.
That's the problem.
You can't trust him to people that want to be in positions of power should never
be in positions of power.
Anybody who wants to be the president,
why the fuck is wrong with you?
You want to run everything really 50,000 a year and you got kids,
you got kids.
Is that what the president makes to 15 years?
I mean,
I guess the,
I get the idea of on paper something,
it's five,
I think it's 500 maybe less.
I don't know.
Brock lesson,
they got half of the efficacy of the beat.
He got 200,000 he got,
well he got 200,000 on paper yet we'll do everything.
Sort of has like paper view deals and when it said 200,000 on paper,
yeah.
I don't know how they work.
The pay scales.
Very tricky.
Right?
They do it.
And I gotta tell you some,
well we came here today because you always say to me every fucking time you can
be,
you always have a fucking story.
No,
you get them from,
I don't know where you get these stores credible.
I've known you my whole life and you keep coming up with new stories.
We came in Lindt
tonight and I seen your family in.
I was really nice to see him.
I seen your wife and it was funny the first time I met your wife,
we met in Vegas at the Riviera and we were sitting there,
great time.
You know what's coming and some chick,
it kept talking to us and then she was really annoying and it turned out to be a
guy that had become a chick and was part of that theater group and next to the
dirty show where we're going to take their clothes off.
She showed us,
she showed us,
but back me on that.
She was beautiful.
She looked good.
She looked like cooking town and then they'd Suda because all she got fired
because they found that she was a man before that.
And then she tried to sue the Riviera or whoever it was and there was one point
at night where I go,
you know I,
at that time I was really crazy.
I had no blow.
And I'm like,
come on,
show me your monkey.
And she showed me and Joe and her pussy and just had a whole board like they
took where her dick was cut it off and took a board drill and took that piece of
me that,
and then they took artificial turf and they put it around his whole and it had
no clip to it.
Like the Clinton,
you can see with stitch time.
And here's the funny thing,
like I thought about this,
I took it to my room afterwards to get high with it.
And you know what?
If I would've done coke and drink,
I would have had to suck my dick just out of general purpose for the story.
Cause she looked great guys.
She knew that Trans Youth,
he was good.
The best description for you say it looked like a bat with its mouth he had with
his mouth open.
It look like this fucking you should is this.
She went back to your hotel room now after we were all hanging out,
there was a bunch of comics hanging out.
All right.
Somebody said,
do you have weed or whatever?
And it was me,
the guy from [inaudible].
Hey,
what's that?
What's that kid's name and that he was with us that night.
He was big.
One is a snuggler he'd show.
No,
he did that.
He was the Riviera has a couple of different rooms and it was me and you and the
dirty room.
And the big room was that kid that it was good friends with Harris.
Pete.
He lived in Montana and he did the rich niner.
Which shiner?
Shiner?
No,
no,
no.
You're not talking about southern black children.
No,
no,
no.
Pub.
Which hall?
Rich Hall.
Yes.
And then I remember we were sitting there.
You laugh and we're both very funny guy and challenge.
Yeah.
Nobody had weed.
And I go unit,
the girl goes,
obviously she had weed.
You know,
she's currently currently smoking in the fucking hotel.
These mother fuckers can't do nothing to me.
You know,
I'm suing him and me,
her and rich hall went up to the room and I remember all of his smoking dope.
And I'm looking at this chicken shit.
If I had coke,
they said both of your destination.
I watch this show and I don't remember what it was.
It was some sort of a documentary,
but I remember being really high and then I stumbled upon it and the show was,
it was all these drag queens,
like a beauty contest for drag queens and Vegas.
It was all transsexuals,
like a full transsexual beauty show.
I was like,
wow,
this is the strangest,
it's fantasy ever.
These guys,
a lot of it.
It was like some weird fantasy thing like this guy had.
He was a fucking man bro.
It is big manly ass face and manly fucking shoulders.
He's taken hormone shots and he's waltzing around on this stage like a ballerina
and I'm like,
this is the craziest Shit I've ever seen in my life.
This guy wants to be a woman so much.
He chopped his cock off.
He's willing to go through hormonal replacements.
You know where they,
they make you actually grow tits.
I said it's like really?
Like lot of people do that more than you would think.
That hormonal thing,
like there's tons of people that do that.
That'd be kind of a different sex.
Yeah.
I want to be a boy.
That's a report the other day on it.
Like how many people are doing that?
Yeah,
chick.
Oh,
she looks a little like Ralphie may just like Ralph in Maine.
She still looks just like Ralph.
It's hysterical.
I met her once,
I met her once in the Sonny and Cher show and she would,
although she was pleasant,
she had a very strange energy.
Sonny,
not Sonny and Cher show Donny and Marie.
Shiny Marines.
Did I say Sonny and Cher?
That's funny.
I was thinking about that because of her,
her uh,
yeah,
I was on the share show where I was
one,
but uh,
no.
Um,
Donny and Marie.
No,
no.
How I got those two confused.
But uh,
she was on it and uh,
I was on,
it was me and Dave Foley and,
and I remember,
you know,
she,
her saying hi,
but there's been this weird thing like I did something,
you know,
you ever meet somebody and they look at you like you did something all the time.
You're like,
I didn't do anything.
What the fuck did I do?
Like a,
like a distance go down.
Yeah.
I mean this one w I mean,
I was not even a notorious person and I hadn't done anything.
I was just,
just an actor,
just fucking there to promote her sitcom.
That's it.
But there was this weirdness,
you know,
and it made me nothing.
It might be my own personal insecurities.
It could be,
but it could be that she's,
this bitch is crazy.
And when it goes from there to,
I don't think I'm a woman,
I'm a man and I need to,
oh,
okay,
well now I understand what that look was all about.
Hey,
let me ask you something crazy on us.
Go Online,
I don't know,
10 15 years ago,
they did a special on one of those 2020s about where people go for that.
For what surgery?
The sex change.
The biggest place is a place in Colorado and the doctor that doesn't,
southern Colorado,
you got to look this up.
I don't know the whole particularly,
but the guy who does it only does it on the weekends.
Oh Geez.
Because during the week he's like a farmer.
What?
And on the weekends he does the trend sexual,
my God,
I've seen you see this,
saw that particularly operations in like a fucking a motel room like an office.
Fucking crazy that you would let another guy cut your dick off and slit you all
in a hometown in Colorado.
I figured for that.
You either go like Israel or Hong Kong or with some smart people.
You know what I'm saying?
But you're going to go let a farmer fucking Dick off and Tuck it in and what is
this guy have like a good reputation.
You haven't seen this.
Maybe it's just a bad man blocker works.
I know he will fucking solid.
Oh my God.
He was booked solid.
You had to make,
but it's a process.
You have to go to psychology and pills.
It's not just,
I want to get my dick cut off.
I could do it in six months and share as you imagine the weirdness that you
would feel if a guy had remorse that you conked cut his cock off.
He's like,
can you go back and fix it?
Like,
Whoa,
no,
we can't.
No,
We can't do those tools.
You can't be personally uracil wraps on.
It's a wrap.
So vulgar a check.
Now there's a lot of checks go through life as a chick.
Is Leather made out of animal skin?
Like is it animal skin?
Straight animal skin.
And you can live off eating skin for some time.
Right?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
I don't know if there's any nutrition in leather.
I mean,
I guess there probably be some really crude protein and fiber.
I mean like you could eat chicken skin and live on,
I think it's a difference in the way it's processed.
The points that when a lead becomes leather,
I don't know someone out there.
I'll answer this question.
I'm always thinking like if you know you're really poor,
you could probably eat shit.
Your shoes,
if they're leather shorts.
I think they did that in depression.
I think that was like a,
you know,
like a common story.
Yeah.
We thought that was just like same.
You're the fucking shoes,
rice and shit.
But they don't on what the fuck are you packing the depression,
man,
that must've been fucking crazy.
1920s they're all walking around,
you know,
shoes,
shoes and shit.
Was it the 20s it was that the depression was one was depression.
Great.
Thirties thirties and then you just gotta hunt through.
Cats eat possums and there's creative ways to cook a fucking rabbit.
You'll learn how to,
how to do it.
You know,
going to the c Charlie Chaplin tonight.
I'm bringing two boots.
Yeah,
big time.
1929 in the lasted until the late 1930s or early forties wow.
11 g shit was 11 years.
Oh my God.
That's a lot man.
Famous footwear where it had been banking to.
That's scary as fuck man.
When you hear shit like that.
A little pressure right now.
The title of it,
the Great Depression.
That shit's depressing,
man.
You're fucking bumming me out.
Yeah.
Why couldn't they could pick a better name for it?
Like the super happy time.
Economic challenge down period.
You know,
call it the economic down.
Everybody's broke,
but what happened?
A good time?
You know,
suppression is a fucking terrible word.
That's just gray film.
That's why I see,
I see black and white movies with crying and blood and suicides.
Yeah.
Did you see that fucking guy tried to commit suicide in the Roman?
I think it was Roman parliament or stuff like that.
The Guy Fucking Swan dives in the middle of this.
Um,
he's in the middle of this,
uh,
well,
you know,
this assembly room and he gets on top of this balcony and fucking jumps and he
lives.
Wow.
Cause he only felt like 30 feet.
He falls in,
slams into these chairs and gets fucked up.
I mean,
he gets fucked up dude,
and he doesn't even try to catch himself,
is trying to commit suicide while he's doing it.
He just lived when I was a kid that got at the bar,
I hung out with,
he tried to kill himself.
His name was Johnny Reid.
He jumped off like a building,
a land and the construction dumpster in lived.
Oh my goodness.
Heads the,
he would fuck.
He was just,
he was just retired one day.
I showed them my Dick.
Well that was like 18.
I put it on the chair next to him.
I tapped him on the show and he goes,
wow.
And that was the end that I had never talked to me again.
Johnny read.
It was around the bathroom.
It was a Romanian parliament.
Sorry.
Sup Dog.
Brian.
Big Pimpin over the holidays looking at you get,
you should see it slinging thing and get my shit.
It's really crazy.
The guy says,
we kit you killed our future and then fucking swan dives.
It's nowhere near high enough to kill him.
I don't know what the fuck he was thinking.
Just attention.
You can live.
Imagine trying to keep the code commits suicide and fucking up and you've got to
be around your friends and you shouldn't do you want to see this guy?
I want to see that fucking Momo jumps off a building and lives.
It should be shot and fucking hunk.
They should arrest You for felony stupid when you do that shit.
That's hilarious.
How committing suicide is against the law.
Is it?
Sure an American too?
Of course.
What happens to you if you commit suicide?
New Fan helps somebody either.
I mean,
look at that Kevorkian.
You know,
people will want to die.
You can't help them,
can help them kill themselves even if they're dying.
And even if they're in horrible,
horrible pain,
you know a lot to help them kill themselves.
That's ridiculous.
There's a certain point in time when people are not going to come back.
You know,
there's a certain point in time when someone's Inter
terrible,
terrible agony.
Help them,
you know,
give him some shit so they don't have to fucking feel that.
Why is that so hard to do?
Why?
How can you lock someone up for that?
You know,
but then you find out about Kevorkian did,
he was really kind of a creepy fuck.
He used to draw the like these horrible,
horrible artwork like about murderers and shit and really like something like
really morose about but of by the Joe Rogan,
if I call you at two in the morning,
you sit here,
your little stall,
I should look that up.
Or watching a movie like call you up and say,
Joe,
I don't want to live in the moment.
Come up my ass.
I'm going to kill myself.
You would say really?
Come on.
Uh Oh.
Hope you know who can lose?
I'll push of Travis.
This is a mother fucker that clearly doesn't know
if it's three o'clock in the morning.
I see Joey d is number of the caller id.
I go,
Oh fuck that motherfucker.
That crazy ass.
Hell is he doing?
I'm going to sleep.
No.
Joey,
what time do you go to bed using my pool?
What time do you call us?
It's always like for,
for then worse.
Lately I've been like not being able to sleep til like five 36 yup.
Are we not?
You're slinging Dick.
You know what I'm saying?
You going to parties for me is writing.
I give my best writing done late at night.
You know,
I just can,
I can think better when the world's asleep.
You know,
there's just something about,
I can go deeper into my head,
you know,
I go the opposite way.
I gotta go to sleep and got up early.
Do you?
Yeah.
I like to get up at three like Monday.
I got up at three last night.
I got up at like three 30 wrote for a little while.
I think my craziest shit at night,
but then I get to fucking stolen.
They got to go back to bed.
I get so fucking stone but three,
four in the morning,
you know,
and I try to keep it on the controlling one bong hit another one and I will lay
the little coffee.
We've got to get you in that tank.
You would fucking love it.
Yeah.
I like all that piece.
Need to get in the isolation thing.
They got one kid can fit in a kid.
Email me the one you can go to the one in Burbank to,
there's one kid fucking call me your buddy.
What's his name?
Craig crash.
Crash.
Avoids his float.
Love Venice.
Venice.
Okay.
Yeah,
he's,
he's the master.
Now after you leave to the mass,
how do you feel?
Can I drive back to you?
Oh fuck yeah.
You don't feel drunk.
Ryan's,
I know you're a hundred percent sober.
You'll feel so relaxed.
When I go to acupuncture and I leave acupuncture on Tuesdays and Thursdays that
not,
I don't plan nothing cause I don't mislead.
Like,
this is why I say it.
Guy.
I know how you love to get blasted.
You like to get high as fuck.
Just blackened by why you're there.
You're eating cookies and shit.
I've had conversations with you.
It's this.
This is a typical conversation with Joey like any,
any given 11:00 PM evening dog tall.
I just say this banana bread fucked up.
Fucked up.
I hide from my wife.
Oh you fuck clone your fucking door Joe Rogan.
Are you fucking funding given me?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking kidding?
No fucking blasted.
Sometimes you would love an isolation tank man because when you get that blasted
and then you climb in the tank,
you go on these journeys man.
It's like the most insane amusement park
ride ever and you can go on these journeys in your own mind like your,
your go.
You go on these fantastic adventures when you're super big special,
have you eat it?
Something about eating it and getting the tank.
Holy Shit.
I have hallucinations man.
I see like a lot of like an animated things.
A lot of like weird cartoons play out a lot of like weird fucking,
I mean really,
but really repeated shit like it repeats itself.
The same sort of themes over and over again and a lot of it is like animated
characters.
It's almost like some crazy fucking Gonzo dimension that you can peer into when
you're super high.
When you're super,
super hot here.
What do we build?
Second type for southwest working for NASA.
You don't even know.
That's a good jacket.
Then Brian gave it to me for Christmas.
What'd you get?
I got to wear it out of respect for retro store in Studio City that just like an
old retro Phillip Clothing store plus what I want to say.
Silly things have so much more comfortable saying silly things like this.
You know?
I think we should do a whole podcast where we just have goggles on.
We would just talk,
talking crazy shit.
I must lost an eye the other day from my cat by the way.
A mother fucker hats were chasing each other.
I was laying on couch.
Cat jumps down and claw hits me quarter of [inaudible] other corner of eye and
right below hitting my eyelid and stuff like that.
And uh,
just like almost ripped like it was your cat's account watch your cat might jump
on you.
He was getting chased by the other cat and man,
you catch it.
Never think that you can jump on your face.
Right.
I think it was like a more of a fall jump.
You got to learn how to smack your cat in the hat,
dude.
It was so you got to make sure that your cat is treating you like a bitch.
Your cat is saying I can,
don't have to run on your shoulder and be considerate.
I'll run on your fucking head.
Yeah.
Cause my comfort is more important to me than you.
Your cat punk to you bro.
And that's bullshit.
That's crazy.
Out of nowhere.
I almost got you do you got to grab your cat by the back of the neck.
You got to grab your cat by the back of the neck and look at them in the eye and
say,
listen,
hooker,
the shinning and a fly.
Okay,
I'm the one who come to the food.
I'm the one who comes to the massages.
You don't call my fucking eyes out shit head and then put them down.
I'll never do it again.
Make sure you've got the goggles on when you say that.
Say fucking scratch you again.
You,
he's just paying me back from a Rodeo cat videos I've been doing with them.
Have you seen that?
And they have this thing where he sits on the back of the chair and I just start
shaking it and he,
he just like holds on as tight as he can and until he falls off.
But he loves it.
He just jumps back up and he's like,
do it again.
Do it again.
So it's like a game you guys.
Yeah,
it's like earthquake.
Yeah.
You have a little agreements with cats like games that you'll play with them.
Right?
I have one cat,
like I,
there's an agreement when I get her on her back and I shake her stomach,
then she's a lot of bite me and kick me and then we're playing.
They were playing like bite me and kicked me.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like we know we both know what we're doing,
you know?
She doesn't really bite me hard and she was really kicked me hard and we're just
like,
oh,
why are you a Yoda?
You know?
It's weird.
You know what I mean?
You get like little agreements with cats,
you know?
Like when,
when it's time to play and dogs too.
Yeah,
yeah.
They know like,
you know,
like Rararara,
they know we're playing now,
oh here we're going to do this thing that we always do.
Like they didn't even know a word of English.
They have no idea how to talk,
but yet they understand how fucking amazing or pets.
I love it.
How fucking amazing.
Right?
If you take care of him,
man,
they're great.
If you love them and take care of them,
love you pat.
And it's just amazing.
That's what,
that's the most and chief excitement I get at three in the morning because my
Kurt,
my cats there so alerted three in the morning,
they're out and I get to feel their nocturnal.
Right.
I could see them fucking around and how they get,
and I get up and I'd like the pope but a fucking labeled with the animals.
I walk my wife to the train at seven I walk back,
I stopped by the two cats in the corner,
a biggie and the,
and uh,
Choco.
And then these two old ladies have a dog and I fucking walk around the block.
Do you really walk it down man?
Yeah,
cause I'd always loved,
Oh,
I fucked.
I love animals.
But every time I come over my house,
Joey's more excited to see my dogs than me.
Oh my God.
It's Ah,
it's something they give you.
And then once you have that understanding with them,
even the [inaudible] visit the dog,
I walk walks around with a muzzle thing.
Yeah.
And I just went up there one day,
fuck you and your muzzle bitch.
You don't intimidate me,
bite me.
Have a bit before and she's like,
you could see it.
She's like one of those shirts.
Shepard mixes.
The once in a while ago,
the head with a hammer when their youngest son,
they'll come back.
Most shepherds,
those fucking Nazi dogs,
those dogs can be very big.
This dog,
she even says it,
the only even says to me,
she goes,
I can't understand what you have with her.
I'm a criminal.
I know these fucking dogs.
I'm an expert.
I'm fucking dog.
And that was a burglar Jack.
You got to know dogs,
you know,
and uh,
I have no love them and stand your ground.
I have no fear of dogs.
I had a dog bite me in the face.
I had a dog,
Paul,
me,
I'd been bit all over my fucking body.
I have no fear of dogs.
I've been better
feral dog.
I got bit by a dog.
Did you really?
Yeah.
This,
uh,
I went over to this person's house that have two dogs that,
that kind of,
they,
they stay outside to guard the house.
You know,
like there's a fence going around the whole entire house.
But they're,
I mean,
they're there,
they're dogs that their family dog,
but they live outside for the majority of the time.
And this dog was barking.
Are they?
They're pretty big.
And about your size of your well,
no,
not,
not like,
uh,
I don't know.
70 pounds.
Yes.
Yeah.
Big Dog.
And uh,
it was one of the things where I was supposed to go around the back and I was
trying to go through the front and the dogs are barking.
I'm like,
Hey.
Oh,
I guess I'm not going to go through the front.
And then my friend calls me,
he goes,
no,
go around back.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
So go around back and he meets me at the gate,
but right when he opens the gate,
the dog just lunges at me and bites me right in the nipple and it hurt and it
was sore.
And then there was like a little,
you know,
bruising over there,
but thick jacket.
Yeah,
I had like a,
like a sweat shirt on or something like that.
But it hurt.
I mean,
it didn't puncture your skin really,
but it was all bruised the next day.
Oh,
what the fuck is wrong with this dog?
I mean,
then after a second he,
I was like,
hey,
that's fucked up dog.
Because the owner was right and
the owner and you were communicating right and that dog didn't realize that
you're a friend.
That's an idiot.
Yeah.
Dogs retarded.
But then like,
like a few seconds after I was in there,
the dog realize,
oh,
it's friends and then was nice.
Get them like a normal dog.
No,
I was slick at pitch.
You heard it like it fucking hurts.
It's not cool.
It came out of nowhere.
I always think like your face,
man.
I always think like,
oh dog lunges at you.
You're,
you're going to be like,
Oh,
you know,
block it or something like,
no,
I was just like,
what the fuck?
Oh,
opposites.
That's the other side of pets,
man.
They are animals.
You and your cat,
your cat want to do attack you man.
You would be,
fuck yeah.
You know,
I had a feral cat for awhile.
Couldn't,
and when they're mad they get crazy and they get nut either terrifying and there
are little tiny things.
Tell you guys some it out to all your viewers at home in three or four years as
a burglar,
I burglarize houses with pit bulls.
Doberman Pinscher,
one drum is shepherd,
the German shepherd.
Rip My Hand Open Brian,
look at the skull.
Look at the squad with a Bob.
Why?
I went right through the fucking thing and then ripped the up.
Jesus,
the worst animal,
Everett and any drug burglary,
burglary I ever had was assigned these cat really friend's house.
I wouldn't go into the house.
I was outside with a gun because I wouldn't let him come down.
He wanted to come down.
All I could hear was this cat goal.
When he was attacking the shit out of them,
attack him.
He comes to the back lane,
drove the jewelry off and the cat was on his head pulling this light till this
day,
that guy still has like a claw in his head.
The just rover over the skin grew over burglarized in that Colombian drug
dealer.
She was a Colombian chick and she would always go into a room and way the coke.
We didn't know why I didn't go.
I didn't know why.
I kept saying,
why don't you pull the room,
bring it out here.
She would always go on the rule.
That's the reason why she had a cat that she couldn't live out.
Whoa.
Girl was always locked and I never seen the cap,
but when we've tried to break into a house,
my buddy seen the fucking cat,
so it was an attack.
Siamese cat attacks I skinny,
one of those skinny,
ugly motherfuckers.
That game was on his head.
At one point he was looking over the balcony and he's like,
I'm coming down the cat.
Will I throw the coke down?
At least drawn the coke down.
The jewelry watched by watch.
The cat was on his head pulling upward and I'll never forget that he had the cut
bite snack trying to pull it off his fucking head and the cat had all four claws
into his head.
It was classic.
I remember going to the pawn shop to sell the jewelry and he had blood all over
his face.
And it's hard to kill a cat.
It's hard.
It was fucking hard.
This was worst animal attack I've ever seen.
And you think about how strong cancer and they're so small,
you know,
it's so scary.
They're so small.
Imagine like a big cat.
Imagine a big imagine getting jacked by a mountain lion.
What the fuck,
man,
you can't get one of those.
You would shit your pants if a fucking mountain like,
and they're so strong too.
That's what everybody says about until if they're going to fucking monsters that
power that everything is just too much.
What a bunch of crazy assholes to keep them as pets.
You know,
there's this,
it's not that hard to get licenses for shit like that.
Like in Nevada,
Mike Tyson had a bunch of shit.
He had like a in
a lion I think in a bunch of shit like that.
There was some dude who got arrested in a,
you know,
oh you didn't get arrested.
He died.
Excuse me.
He was in,
um,
ah,
thank you.
Is in Harlem and he had a tiger and a crocodile and like a bunch of shit in his
apartment.
Dude had an apartment with a tiger in it.
Wow.
He had a tiger in a cage in his fucking apartment.
Do you know about that fucking designer?
About that bus?
Recently in La there that bus with all the cats,
there was like 240 plus 240 cats and like this woman had like one of those in
one house.
Storage,
storage,
uh,
like you know where your rent storage and it was still with cat with 240
[inaudible] and 50 cats.
Half of them were like dead and she had like some kind of like sickness where
she had to take care of all these cats.
Oh my God.
It's crazy.
It was in California like two weeks ago.
So yeah,
right down the corner here.
Fucking Pomona,
one of those places,
240 fucking cats.
That's fucked up.
Is it ever going to be possible to fix people of that?
Is it ever going to be w are we ever going to have a society where there's no
people who have 250 fucking cat's dying and shit all over themselves at a
storage container now,
because that's the test.
Is it possible watch waters,
watch fucking mortars,
right?
But whatever.
What's the difference between them and you?
The best was the best episode of hoarders.
There's,
when they pull something up and go,
oh,
what's this?
And they pull up like a dead cat lady goes,
that's what happened to kitty.
I'm like,
wait a second on cat disappeared in your fucking house four years ago.
You didn't smell it.
You didn't see it.
It's just,
Oh,
I mean,
you got to watch.
I don't watch it every day,
but if I was switching channels and hoarders is on,
I fucking watch.
Human beings have a horrendous smell when they're dying.
Oh,
please.
he lives in an apartment building and this lady died.
She just died in the house.
The Old Lady.
And uh,
she was a fucking mean cunt too,
by the way.
This old lady and uh,
nobody was happy,
happier than me.
She like when she died,
she was creepy,
creepy old lady.
Anyway,
she,
uh,
she died and we were walking by her house or apartment and it just stuck.
The smell is so successful that goes in your nose,
that stays,
that goes into your throat.
It makes you,
it's worse than any other animal.
Smell.
Dead.
I've smelled a bunch of dead animals.
There's nothing like a human humans.
We've got a very particular reason.
God,
from a block away,
funk ass from a block away smelled a dead human listening to her.
When I was a kid,
I was about eight or nine.
I used to live in two oh five west,
88th street during the week with the Jews.
Nice white people,
right,
right.
They Amsterdam where you boy lives.
But then in the summers I would go to 148 sheets to my godmother's house and
there was two dimensions.
The kids on 88th street wear nice kids that played wiffle ball and organize.
You went up to another 40 Asian at first.
Those motherfuckers at these,
you want to see a dead body.
And we'd go out to the George Washington bridge,
take our bikes to
go see a body that we weren't going to report.
Holy Shit,
we didn't report nothing in those days.
That body was Dan for fucking weeks.
Oh my God.
I remember being eight or nine.
Then we'll come on,
let's go.
And we write out by,
come on the bottle.
Here we go,
fucking kids.
And all the sudden they,
you go and they put boards on top of them from a block away.
You could hear the fly,
the fly,
you could hear it makes the flies go fucking nuts.
And then in [inaudible] 94 I had a buddy,
God bless his soul,
work on a dump and Lyndhurst New Jersey and he made like 50 grand a year,
but he'd been in a hundred grand a year.
Every month somebody put envelopes in this fucking day because they don't
really,
they don't really break up the recyclables,
right.
They just dump them all into one.
That's what the mob was doing.
He was working at a dumpster is part of a city job and I'm in my way.
I borrowed his car,
wants to do comedy,
he goes,
Doug,
you want to see a foot like a dead body?
And it was under rubble,
like garbage.
Just going into fucking that Elizabeth,
all that Shit Jersey with the garbages.
So as you come off that exit,
it smells like ass.
You just get used to it.
He was used to,
yeah.
He,
you know,
walk up to me,
go,
come on.
You want to see fucking a dead body.
You go out for miles.
They'd be ratchet on right in front of you.
And he'd be talking to him like it was nothing.
I see a rat,
I shit my pants.
I'm spots where you drives you in New Jersey where it smells so bad.
How the fuck this be legal?
What are they doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
Everything smells like shit.
There's one thing with cows that happens with cows.
Have you ever been by a cow farm?
Yeah.
When dairy farms and you know when there's a lot of cows,
man,
my,
my family used to live in Pennsylvania and they lived in Barre,
like out in like kind of abandoned in there and let the row
who else had,
there's a one dude who had a whole bunch of them,
got patty,
Patty and described Patty.
Um,
so,
uh,
you drive,
I would drive to go visit them and they had a pass through this whole area where
there was cows and fucking a,
it smelled bad for like a half an hour drive
for a full half an hour has smelled like Egor up in that shit.
You start getting used to it,
but isn't that okay?
I get that you would get used to it,
but aren't you taking something into your body when you're smelling that mean
it's not as simple as you're just smelling it,
right?
You're smelling that there's particles in the air and you're breathing that in
as well.
If it's that insanely offensive to your nostrils.
Isn't that some sort of a warning that your body's not supposed to have that
inside of it or it's some kind of natures way of trying to get you to produce
smelling ass and so now you want to fuck cows or something.
You know what I mean?
I could smell the ass.
You know how you're trying to trick you and now like animals when they trying to
breathe,
they smell each other's ass and stuff like that.
Like dog smell each other's ass and like animals smell each other's butts.
Right?
Maybe there's some kind of weird hidden try it.
Nevermind
you will you be talking to like,
fuck dude,
I tried to listen to you on that.
I tried to go with you and then talking to from the sense of like that movie
where they showed them every hand.
I'm seeing that these particles,
you're smelling this just the effect you're going in your body in the past.
It's not just,
I mean it's a fine shit mist in the air is what it is.
I grew up by the Meadowlands.
That's why people look at me.
You should smoke from a humidifier bitch.
I'm putting the metal and the fuck you benefit by lights better for your lungs.
Bits.
I swam in the Hudson.
Oh,
humidity.
I slept the hug.
Did she really swim in the Hudson on the Hudson when I was a kid.
You go all in at once or twice and he'd jump in.
See a CEO that you fucking come up with a with a,
with an IOL on top of you,
you know,
and a foot bad.
His ideas.
Oh,
it's hard.
This is 20 years ago when there was a place towards under the bridge,
like nobody goes fish in that,
right?
No,
no.
He's a hilarious that that's just accepted.
It's accepted that there's going to be a certain amount of pollution and they
were just,
listen,
fuck this river.
We're just going to dump our shit in this river.
There's seven fucking billion people live in this one.
Tiny island fucked a river.
You can't fish in the river.
It's accepted that that's plywood.
Fucking go in there,
but I'll tell you what's crazy in those days,
Puerto Ricans are coming from the Bronx on the weekends.
It must be someone who fishes in it.
No,
there are definitely people listen to people will fish,
but the Puerto Ricans would come down with a Volkswagen and take 90 people out
there in the Congo drama the couch.
Have you ever drove by a paper mill before?
That Shit's disgusting.
That is the worst smell.
There's a whole association.
The Hudson River Fisherman's association sounds hot.
Is that Hudson River Strike Bass.
New York harbor.
Where's that?
I would fucking swim.
Drink that water.
Nothing.
Even that plane that landed fucking,
that's all rusty now.
That plane that will sell,
he landed them mother fuckers.
They tried to take it on a wheel.
Fell out that she'll eat.
Rice can be a skin fishing in New York harbor.
Is that a,
is that right there?
They fished down by the light.
By the village down there like all of abide by by they do.
They do by Wall Street.
That'd be fucking sick fucks that which fish out there by a,
we're going to statue of Liberty.
Wow.
Very strange.
I would need any other,
I did see my friend Mike asked at least one time,
get an email out of the Hudson.
It open and eat his fucking heart.
Something crazy.
It was like those emails look like little snakes,
but he ate an eel fucking one time and heels head.
Oh yeah,
they got some serious fucking problems here.
Oh please.
PCPS.
Chemicals.
Discovered the other day talking about all the different,
this is like way back.
Listen Bro,
let me explain something to you.
You've got a bridge.
You've got the bridge,
you've got the bridge.
You got a New York City Harlem and you got New Jersey,
northern New Jersey.
You got that bridge.
Every day a cop pulls the kid over,
the kid grows and drugs out the window.
If that's happened every day for 30 years,
that one is fucked.
That water is disgusting there with George Washington was there and he shot
cannon balls at the Indians across the fucking don't.
Doesn't the sewers empty out into that to the sewers,
empty out into the oceans.
What happens there?
When I was a kid,
we,
there was a Charles River.
It's in Boston and there was a branch of it was by my house and uh,
we used to go there hanging out and we were walking
across this little area and a,
I saw something bubbling up in the water and I looked at it and I was like,
what the fuck is that?
It's like some,
it's like a broking,
something like a pipe.
Cause there's like a flow of water that's coming up and I see all these things
floating in it.
And then I saw a condom and then I realize what it is.
I saw lumps of Shit.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Like this is shit water.
They just pouring directly into the river.
It's coming out in a big flow.
Like I don't know if it was a broken pipe or is just how they dump it off.
That's what they,
I don't trust water available.
First of all is this trust that shit in the bottle.
The bottom where all four.
Listen Bro,
we're all fucking bullshit.
What's that?
What's your buddy's Panatella did the best show ever?
Water?
Yeah,
about disorder.
Where it comes from.
San Antonio from some fucking guys are,
the people say comes from Alaska,
but the best was when they went to Beverly hills to a water bar and they were in
there.
They would take water from a hose and giving it to these fucking Bobos in
Beverly Hills.
Oh my God.
This water's water.
Water bars.
And these idiots are like,
oh my God,
this water.
I could feel that nuttiness France bitch.
It goes into my hoes and fucking la.
That's been nuttiness from France.
You know,
my wife is a big water filtered $300 every month.
I tried to prove a point.
I got a glass of water I filled in.
I left the cabinet for two days.
It was fucking green due days.
Oh,
did I tell you what happened to me?
I had a water cooler.
One of those,
you know,
like hot,
cold water coolers with,
they chug jugs,
had it for like three years,
you know,
never thought anything of it,
just replaced it.
Every time I emptied whatever notice the other day,
uh,
it was headed like this green tint to it.
I'd like.
The Sun was shining through the window at the right point and I was like,
wow,
that looks a little green,
you know?
And I poured it in a glass and looked at him like,
no,
it looks fine.
Then I went somewhere on the road with you,
came back and it looked a little bit greener and I'm like,
why that is green now?
I said,
I took it out,
looked inside the tank,
everything looked clean and stuff.
As I started to freak out,
it started tasting and smelling a little weird.
Finally I called the company up and I'm like,
you know what's going on here too?
It seems like it's getting a little green by looking site and everything is
fine.
They're like,
oh,
you have to clean those out like every three months.
You know that,
right?
And I'm like,
Whoa,
I've had this for three years.
Never cleaned it out.
Once.
They're like,
they're like,
yeah,
take it apart.
So I took it apart.
Just green mold underneath.
The thing just has been,
I've been drinking swamp water for the last,
you go $15 a month.
And so then they're like,
they're like,
no,
you must wash it out with bleach and all this crap.
So I fucking washed it out with Billy.
Yeah,
they like put put bleach in there and stuff.
Like what is this product again when it's like a water cooler,
you know how like you would get the jugs like arrowhead water and put it on the,
on the thing that one of those things you have to clean.
Yes.
You're supposed to clean that.
I'd never knew this.
I you're supposed to clean that thing out like every three to six months is what
they told me.
And I've had mine for three years.
Yeah.
They said like a cup of like a little tab of bleach and mix it with water,
run it through a couple times.
It started running it through a couple of times and whatever happened,
like the bleeds,
somehow it started eating away at some of the metal.
So then I put another jug on.
I thought it was all cleaned out,
pour my glass of wine or I looked down this time there was like all these little
black dots in there and I'm like,
what are all these black guys found out?
Like the bleach had like descended,
disintegrated something or I don't know what the mold disintegrated something
and now I was drinking like metal through the fucking thing out.
Now I'm like,
fuck,
what do I do?
I don't know if I want to go back that way.
Bottled water seems like the way to go,
you know,
drink it and throw it away.
It's really interesting for my sleep apnea machine that has a reservoir,
you put water into two humidifier so it keeps your throat,
uh,
moist at night.
Lord,
it's so weird.
I'm supposed to put distilled water in there,
right.
And I put the stone water in there all the time.
The is great.
I cleaned out once a week with bleach and the whole thing.
When I go on the road,
I don't use distilled water.
And it's very interesting.
I could tell you where,
who's got the dirtiest fucking waters after I'd come home from the road.
Really like Arizona is disgusting.
Fucking that Tucson trip we took when we go for the UFC.
Um,
just last month we went down there for something not to a Arizona state.
Yeah,
we did the Wednesday night that uh,
no,
Austin,
the fucking filter was disgusting when I got back.
So not Arizona or I was tossed to the Texas Gray Shit.
Really when I went to Arizona.
That's why one time I went to Arizona,
this year when I came back,
it was a three night trip.
The fucking machine was gray from the water.
So I could tell the local water and even if I buy bottled water comes back
clean.
But sometimes it just the local water from the bathroom,
I could tell you just from that machine who's got the good water and the dirty
water.
Arizona's house it recently.
Um,
there was some,
some study that was published that showed 31 different cities have elevated
levels of,
of,
of certain chemicals that they believe might be carcinogens in the water.
31 cities.
Yeah,
elevated levels.
Some of them like 200 times the level that they think would be appropriate.
And they all have prescription drugs in them.
Yup.
Yeah.
All prescription drugs in them.
People will flush their shit down the toilet.
Right.
Okay.
So our,
our dicks are going to get harder.
Are All going to have,
we're going to get a pregnant
thinking about that man.
What?
I mean they're not levels though that the are they levels that you can,
I don't know.
But what if,
because like one of the wet weight psychoactive levels of drugs that are,
if ever been found in really,
right,
isn't it?
Why not?
I think it's like parts per million.
I think it's to the point that like,
like birth control starts getting into the water to where everyone who drinks
water cannot get pregnant anymore.
Well,
Tony's get point to stop flushing their birth control pills.
Could you imagine if you're such a whore,
you have so much birth control pills that when you flush them,
nobody can get pregnant.
That's what a whore you are.
You fucking pig.
How much is lay off the deck?
That's going to take a billion pills and keep stuffing Cox in your clam.
Because what they're saying is like the prescription drug gets in the water and
it can't get out of the water.
They can't take it out of the water anymore.
Candy?
No.
So,
so the,
the more,
the longer we live,
the more that chemical is going to be put into the water,
to the water,
to the water side.
I don't know about that.
I think they must,
it must break down over time or does it get worse?
Oh No,
I would imagine.
I mean if,
if something,
you know,
it's going to be getting filtered somehow or another.
I mean the population of Earth has doubled since what the 1950s and so our water
might be being fucked.
It might be getting fucking like,
we don't even realize that our water at one point we're not going to be able to
drink it because if we drink it and you're allergic to penicillin,
you're going to break out in hives and everything's made out of water.
What it will,
that's fucking scary.
Scary thing that we started would take a shower and you come and you smell like
somebody else that's fucking dirty water that's recycled.
Fuck
can,
uh,
when,
when you're eating pasta,
you know,
and you,
you boil water,
you know that that water is still that flunky water from the fucking sick,
you know.
So even if you tried to drink bottled water all the time,
we really making spaghetti with bottled.
I do too.
I really is that the move is the move,
right?
You won't,
they say the boil water anyway.
If you blow water,
it comes back pretty clean and pretty clean.
But not everything.
You don't kill everything.
You don't tell a lot of the chemicals.
Fucking water.
Fucking yeah.
Water Man.
There needs to work.
They need to find,
they need to find a substitute for water.
But anything that would be a substitute for water would be made from water.
Joey,
do you know anything about the Juggalos?
What's the Juggalos do you know anything about insane clown posse?
Nothing.
This is a crazy meal going to learn.
Yeah,
to crazy movement.
There's fucking millions of these guys following the insane clown posse all
around the country wearing makeup and shit.
And they're all like this motley crew of unfortunate tattoos and she's fucking
strange dental structure and you know,
they're,
they're a trip man.
It's,
it's a,
a giant fucking movement.
Now what did you bump into these people and then bumping into him?
I'm just like seeing it online.
It's one of those things that like kind of snuck up out of nowhere.
So what do I have to do to become a juggler?
I'm going to go [inaudible] you gotta be,
you gotta be into the insane clown posse now that's a rap band.
Yeah.
That's the one that Dante people make fun of them.
Honestly,
Dante had a fight with one of those guys.
I don't know what they from Hollywood.
Dante,
which Dante.
Dante.
Really?
We know to the comic to fuck him.
I'm talking about Black Dante.
Dante.
He got in a fight with in insane clown guy.
Let me telling you to,
I don't remember this.
Tell me his story.
I don't know the store.
I don't know what a dog now they hang out in Hollywood.
These people,
correct?
I don't know.
I don't know much about them.
This is,
this happened five years ago with Dante and Dante got in a fight with on of
them.
Dante is a big boy.
Yeah.
You got to see him down.
That's not a good move to get [inaudible].
He's getting ready for football,
so he's been running.
I seen him football.
There's any 40 he played semipro football.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Yeah.
When did you start playing again?
Five years ago.
Really?
All Dizzy.
I think he's about 31 it's football.
It's all 31 is bullet.
Who is bullet wound is healed.
That's one of the funniest things you could ever say.
He's ready to play.
His bullet wound is healed.
He got shot in the leg of a drug.
It
is c two o this coconut water and stuff.
Love Shit.
They sent me home [inaudible].
I been drinking.
That shift for two,
three years I was playing for was awesome.
This is the best one I've ever found.
I liked the Zico.
Zico is good town.
Did they?
I've been buying those in like the cartons now at the grocery stores now carry
him like almost like in milk carton type things.
And then it's like you made three 99 by,
it's pretty good.
But I still like c two o better.
I just wish,
you know I like this cause I like it's a big can 17 ounces and what you then do
is take it out of the can and put it over rice.
Yeah.
That's the Patois dot.
[inaudible] it is none other than put it over ice and you'll see what it's like.
Coke one ice cubes.
This guy fucking cyanide and I'm co one coq one is okay,
but with ice cubes you take your fucking drinking coffee.
So you drink bottled water,
ice cubes to you do that sometimes.
Yeah.
I like that.
That's been making Daiquiri's with it.
With the coconut water,
that gets fucked up.
My Dad has a happy hour every day.
He sits in the backyard.
They both retired my uh,
and so,
so he just gets hammered every day.
Every day at five six o'clock they'll sit back and have a couple of during that
hammered,
but like,
like two or three days.
Yeah.
It gets lit everyday.
Wow.
You have taken,
Huh?
Does he take care of himself?
Oh yeah.
He works out every day because that's what I thought.
It was funny like your dad did.
Dad's a very smart guy,
right?
Yeah.
Very sorry.
They is some sort of inventor character yet.
Engineer,
inventor trying to break perpetual motion in his basement type kind of guy kicks
down a window.
If he wants to build a greenhouse and they go back,
I'm going to build a greenhouse.
It just smashes a window out and builds a greenhouse with a hot tub in it.
Like your car breaks down,
you'll take the car engine out,
throw it on the ground.
He's,
it's crazy how if the internet was around when,
when he was growing up,
he would be at mad programmer or he'd be a huge computer nerd,
which is crazy cause he would have lost all those skills,
you know,
like building cars and tearing down walls because he would have been addicted.
You could tell he would have been addicted to the Internet.
Wow.
Do you ever try to get them into it now?
Yeah,
but I mean he has the same computer I,
I got,
I'm like seven years ago.
Do you ever ask him like how come he's done into it?
Uh,
I think he is into it,
but I think he just,
I mean it's weird like people having a laptop is completely different.
You know,
like if you had a computer in a computer room,
you'll probably not use it as much as if you had a laptop on the couch,
laptop in bed.
I think the laptop is that the crack for people.
Once they get a laptop,
your dad probably doesn't know where to begin.
He probably doesn't know.
I mean,
but that's why it's so curious to me that your dad is so intelligent and so
curious that why wouldn't he be like all over the net?
Why would it be online every day?
Like reading new things?
He does documentary.
I think it does to a point.
You just,
it doesn't take it to the advantage because he's hooked on this shit dog.
There's other things to fucking life to.
No,
I understand.
Just because you're smart don't mean you got to sit on this fucking thing all
day either.
You know know what I'm saying is once in a while you move on with the guys like
whole life.
Oh No,
I understand.
The whole fucking life.
The guy's a super curious guy.
That's all I'm saying.
But,
but when you're a guy like Brian and his dad is a lot like Brian,
like you would say like,
man,
like you don't know you're missing a lot of people.
They did.
It's never [inaudible] 60 [inaudible] 60 means these.
That means he's getting one foot in the grave worn or banana peel.
By the time he starts learning about it's like me wiling to take acid.
Why didn't take ecstasy?
Because I was already hooked on coke.
I got enough problems for coke.
I'm gonna open up a fucking thing.
Access you now,
same thing with his dad.
He's smart enough.
You don't need to fucking look at computers.
He wants to sit in the back of the drink.
Coconut water factories.
He is equated a man looking at computers as to why you would or something
fucking years old.
You'd think he's got time.
You don't want to be like,
if he wants to get his dick slept.
You know what I'm saying?
Before he dies.
That's why he's drinking daiquiris and having a good time on the bath night.
Do you want him out there with a fucking thing like this fucking mobile playing
on a thing,
taking pictures of the cat.
That guy's got,
I think die.
I understand that.
I think that reading things on the Internet,
it makes life more interesting.
Oh,
I read shit every day,
but I'm not going to live on there and fucking,
you know you got to do other shit.
Yeah,
for sure.
You have to go live your life and I mean fuck that shit.
Being on it all the time.
It's not the look but being on it or not at all.
It's not the move either.
No,
but you can't believe everything you fucking read on there anyway because a
fuck.
I'm going to sit there and watch the documentaries,
everything.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I'm living life.
I'm doing my own motherfucking documentary,
I believe.
Like what's his name?
What's his name?
The guy that he,
the turners husband like turn.
We're making a home movies.
You're writing a home books.
Fuck these bitches.
You know what I'm saying?
He gotta be there on the all day about to send me and fucking who gives a fuck.
It's random for four days out there.
The one on ones backed up the pieces.
Give a fuck about some fucking now Joey,
when are you going to eventually die off of my space?
Because I've noticed you still do your blogs.
I couldn't let blackening never gone off.
Here's the deal.
If my space goes away,
it goes away and then burned out there.
That'll take away all your blogs.
I got him up.
I got on on wordpress.
They'll leave.
Think you're dealing with it.
Some fucking novice.
What's with the questions?
You ready for the school?
Fucking paper.
It's Christmas going.
Fucking Brian.
Why do you care if he's unmarried?
Cause I'll tell you why.
I don't want to go on to different things.
I thought you guys.
Why?
Because my Twitter people are a little fucking crazy and that like you
motherfuckers.
That's why I put the blog on Twitter after I do it on my space.
My Facebook people,
I've got family people on there and I got people that have kids on there and
they look at a lot of shits.
I gotta be careful that saying that,
which is perfect.
That's what my space,
I'm proven a fucking point that we got to stop being sheep people.
You got to stop jumping on the next big fucking thing.
You know?
By the time,
by the end of the year,
we'll have 10 fucking g's on an iPhone.
You've got all of them.
You got to relax.
You got to control yourself,
and this is what I'm going to stick to for a while.
I'm just going to say,
I'm just gonna say,
I thought I didn't know you had it like two cops because my space,
in my opinion,
one day it's going to go well,
please.
It's garbage
can go where it's pretty bad and they're,
they're,
they're the main people back off.
They changed drowning in Los Right now.
Money.
Isn't that incredible that they used to be so huge,
just a short period of time ago.
That is the most fickle thing I think I've ever asked law society now a days.
I know we're on something for six months and we move on.
That's not good.
Liberal fucking told you.
What's Facebook starting to go down a bad path though lately or that'd be
noticed that I've been getting like spam from fucking comics and Bob Levy or
whatever his name is called leaving land.
I think I've blocked the guy,
have unfriended the guy,
but somehow I'm still getting fucking two messages a day about leaving land USA
and I'm like,
all right,
this is impossible.
I believe he's my friend.
I go into your settings and I,
fuck.
Yeah,
you probably do add leave every time samples
Bob on hill.
No,
they did got rid of Bob.
We'll put them back in.
That was the beginning stages of my space.
If every fucking week ago with a new fad or a new fucking thing,
we've got to put the foot down Joey each.
I'm just proud of you that you're online.
I remember when you weren't even online.
I remember when you wouldn't make texts messages.
I remember I still don't do texting.
I didn't want to have a phone would cut them out again.
The pages find pages fine or need a fucking phone.
No fucking phone.
I want people calling me and telling me Shit.
So you stop text messaging.
Yeah,
I cut it out.
What happened?
Because people too much to much text messaged me if there's a dollar bill number
at the end of it.
Yeah.
Don't text message to me.
Some stupid shit.
I'm waiting for a little like just call me.
Don't text messaged me some shit.
That makes me think you just need a hug.
Yeah,
I don't need that shit.
My man.
You know somebody sends you a message.
It's like on Facebook.
I love Facebook.
I love Twitter,
but somebody sends you money.
They want to have a conversation on that.
All that conversation on Facebook type of what?
You got to talk to me.
I'll tell you,
we'll move on with your life.
Then they write you back.
Thank you for what the fuck.
Let it go.
Move on to the next fucking mobile.
You know what I'm saying?
How long do you want to city?
I can't do that.
I can't do that at all.
I don't my,
you don't type that well either.
Right.
So it takes you a well black type,
you know,
I type,
I,
I'm better than I was before I took type it two years of typing in high school,
but that was 20 years ago on 30 million fucking joints.
You know,
Mavis beacon teaches typing.
I used a computer program.
That's how I learned that.
It's fun.
They make it like a game,
you know?
That's how I learned it.
I'm not that good though.
I'm decent.
I know.
You're really good.
I've seen you.
You're very,
you're very good.
I just,
you know,
uh,
I'm having a good time with the computer.
I write a lot on the computer,
but no more text messaging now.
Too much used it.
Right.
Those thought,
listen,
I just don't like people that they're using this business.
That's why I didn't like,
I didn't let you know.
If you want me to do your fucking,
she'll call me.
Hey,
are you available Tuesday the eighth on his business?
I don't want no mix ups.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
I understand this.
I understand that.
Yeah,
I agree.
Just call me.
Call me something a couple of weeks ago that I didn't understand.
You told me,
you told me you go,
you don't understand Joe.
When you get busier the computer bitch,
when you were doing news radio there was no computer.
You will get Sussman was calling you direct direct call me bitch won't text me.
You can definitely get more things by no because call me,
I'm sick of calling me.
I'm almost,
if I could take that as an option out I will probably do it.
So there's certain things though that you have to get done with the
conversation.
Yeah,
but still the majority caulk conversations I get in conversations on a message
board.
I go fuck what
kind of can of worms and I open up here cause this is going to take a long time
to really truly explain.
It's going to,
it's all very,
very evolved subject.
And that's too wild.
I can't,
I don't have the time,
man.
I not only,
it's not even a time thing.
I don't have the effort.
I'm too,
I'm too focused and too many different areas.
Like I try to like on message boards especially,
I try to put in as much time as I can and talk about stuff and you know,
and go back and forth with things.
But fuck man,
I got so much other shit to do.
It's like,
it's really like,
it's,
it's counter productive to me to like get into any like really deep discussion.
Those things become a huge pain.
But also when I'm doing something,
I'm in a mindset,
you know,
and the phone rings and they're,
I'm just like,
fuck this.
I can't,
you can't answer this cause it's gonna ruin my thought process.
That's why I like texting because when I'm done with something I just go with
it.
Okay.
Yes.
No blue,
purple vagina.
Right.
Well that's when you want like trivial subjects on a message board and you want
to go,
they just cured,
uh,
aids with stem cells hole in.
You want to look at that and just type Holy Shit.
We can fuck with condoms,
would no condoms now,
you know,
I mean it's like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like you don't,
you don't get in some gigantic debate about something,
you know,
just something fascinating and interesting.
But those are the ones that when you get drawn into a man,
those go on for it.
These can go on for days and days because it's such an ineffective way to
communicate.
You know,
you write something out and then I write a response and I wait for you.
It's like fucking God damn,
that's time consuming.
You like Twitter cause the hundred and 40 fucking words.
And I'll tell you what,
if I see six,
seven in a row that someone sends me and they just,
they're just,
oh,
you're crazy.
Click blocked.
You can't,
you can't take up my whole thing.
Just trying to communicate with me about every fucking thing you can think.
I hate it.
Yeah,
it gives becomes annoying.
But the beautiful thing is that you could stop,
that.
You can stop people from just clogging it up.
I just banned people.
I'm like,
if they start like just acting a fool,
then I just,
but there's plenty of cool people on a too.
People are always sending me cool Twitter links and they're always sending me
interesting stories and interesting,
you know,
interesting videos.
I get great views,
interesting music.
That shit.
Cool musics in cash.
Great Link last night somebody sent me I hadn't seen in 15 fucking years.
So what was it,
the Bruce Lee,
uh,
Chuck Norris fight from the [inaudible] from the coliseum.
Seem trivial to you,
but if you haven't seen it in 15,
20 years,
you're like,
wow,
that's fucking great.
That's a great classic man.
He starts boxing them and the cats are running around and if you know anything
about the Roman Coliseum,
they got a movie that's walking around that,
sorry.
That's what they filmed that at the coliseum.
I don't know,
because the first scene is a set and they turn the camera around.
It looks like the Colosseum,
they're there or they did some footage there,
but it's so weird.
Like if you don't anything about the Colosseum,
ma'am.
Like I said,
they have 20 million fucking cats walking around that it's just infested with
generations and generations.
We've
been there,
man.
I want to go though to Rome.
You really want to go?
Yeah,
I want to,
I want to go to Rome and I want to go to Athens.
So I want to see a,
I want to see the Parthenon,
the Acropolis.
I want to see all that crazy shit.
You know?
That was an amazing time and it's amazing that they were so advanced as far as
like the incredible buildings that we're creating.
But then nobody even bothered fixing them.
Nobody even bothered keeping them up.
Like society had crumbled so far that they became rubble.
You know,
some of the most incredible structures like the people that built them,
you know,
you've got to go.
What happens when the people that made this incredible quality of building,
what happens when they just die off?
What happens when no one can do that shit anymore?
What happens when,
you know,
you go through a few generations and no one knows how to fix the ceiling anymore
because no one's like,
or a carpenter to the level that these people were back then.
Then they just start rotting out,
you know,
and then it becomes nothing.
It's pretty fucking nuts when you think of like look at their,
the houses that are around,
if you look at,
look at the surrounding area of Rome or of Athens,
they're all normal modern houses now,
you know,
but yet here's these insane stone structures that have stood the test of time
and you never hear from a thousand years ago and this amazing architecture and
incredible,
you know,
precise craftsmanship all just a thousand years ago.
You know,
it's pretty amazing stuff.
Genius and it all fell apart.
All fell apart.
You know,
it's crazy bro.
Going back to that thing about cannibalism because the foot,
none of them,
cause I was thinking that last night or the night before,
there was a show on a APL about the history of the cats are some,
yeah,
they were talking about Egypt and all that with the tombstones.
And what was going on.
People were dying.
Right.
And what they were doing is,
let's say somebody died,
there was their favorite cat.
They want the cat to go on the journey with Whoa Shit.
Go.
Cause they would take them in to get them a modified.
Yeah.
But before they'd love a Phi,
they break their neck to make sure that they would never leave.
Do you follow him?
Say Anthea.
So once you went to the s the life,
the soul would go to that life with you.
But if you broke the cow,
all the cats next that were modified,
all the cats that would love a five,
the next were broken.
How do you know that's just not how they both,
I guess what they were talking about on the show last night.
Well that's what they were doing.
If somebody had a favorite cat,
they died.
The cat live.
Okay,
we kill the cat.
So you can take the journey with them and they would,
uh,
wrap him up and shit like that.
Egyptians were like really into cat.
Yeah.
Really at the cats too much.
But it makes it lifts your eyebrows about what the fuck were they really
thinking about?
There was such a smart civilization and so kinky and shit,
but they knew something like if your cat died in those times and you had before
you bury GCAT,
you're gonna to take them to some guy in the neighborhood.
That guy thought you abused at cat.
They kill you.
What?
Oh,
fucking they had the records of all the cats in the neighborhood.
It's a crazy that they worshiped cats,
you know,
t to tuck common,
uh,
King Tut and um,
his father ochin Naughton,
they were both like a deformed.
They both had like extra long heads.
They both had like these weird physical,
like some sort of a deformation of their head.
They had like extra long heads when they found a,
his dad and all the depictions of them look like that too.
I think his name is [inaudible] and uh,
in,
in two comma,
if you look at all the images of them,
they all have like these weird kind of long heads.
It's really a trip,
man.
I wonder if like there's a few instances of people,
you know,
back in those days,
I mean,
if you look at like what Egypt was able to accomplish,
I wonder if there were like some super fucking rain man,
mother fuckers,
just a few super rain man,
motherfuckers that just defied all the current,
you know,
current,
uh,
like,
Iq level,
Iq levels,
intelligence levels,
just,
just a few fucking freaks,
a few weird freaks.
You know,
like every now and then as a dude who's born in Lexington Lexington's deals,
Dick,
you know,
dude's got like a 14 inch deck that's not normal,
but it's so far above normal.
It's like what happens there?
You could get a can of brain be born like that.
Can you get a 14 inch Dick Brain?
You know,
cause if you can,
could you imagine?
Yeah.
But was he just really good at like,
wow,
I could build shoes better than this person.
You know,
they were just smarter for that time period.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know what aquanaut and accomplished or what to Tuck.
Cut Ting to Todd common.
He died when he was really young and know those people.
Yeah,
some of them did.
How old?
35 40 he was,
oh,
I think it was Moses.
One of one of them lived so long that by the time he died,
every one that was alive had been born during his title reign and there were so
they were concerned that when he died that the world would end there.
They had not,
they had not known life without this guy.
I forget which one that was not really like big up on my Pharos.
It's too much to think about,
man.
I've,
I've watched these a Egyptian documentaries like a magical Egypt's fascinating
shit,
but it's like six fucking hours,
at least six hours of DVDs and it's like you're trying to pay attention and keep
track and you're like,
whoa.
Like if you really wanted to like lose your mind,
get,
get into Egypt,
get into studying ancient Egypt because it's so complicated and so surreal that
you like,
look at these people.
They drew these,
their language consistent of nutty stick figures and they were all about stars.
And transcending this life.
And,
and yet they made the most insane structures ever known to men.
Like they were like a super psychedelic culture with pump Payette.
I don't know India,
right?
Yeah.
That's bumped.
Layton,
Bombay Pompei Pompa.
Nosen Pompei let's find out.
No,
because I seen that the pink Floyd,
the concept,
and they put it on DVD like these days in Italy.
Pompei it's in Italy,
pom pom.
Pei Pei.
It's in a,
it's a province of Naples playing Floyd live on Pompei fucking tremendous.
They said the equipment out there,
that dog side of the moon.
I'm wondering what it's like going back to the old country and hanging out with
those Italians.
I bet they're fucking free bread sticks to the other of gun [inaudible] I bet
they're freaks.
I heard the best foods in Spain.
Really?
The food is off the chain.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I heard from places like that.
Right?
Like the passion places like Spain and France and Italy,
like these that were,
they're considered like real passionate,
you know,
like a passionate,
passionately European countries such as we just go over and have a good time.
But German is my God.
We went to actually,
and it was just,
I love it when you do that,
but it's interesting,
like German is not considered passionate.
They're not,
they're considered cold and calculated and their food kind of sucks.
I mean,
yeah.
Then the wiener stencils and shit like that and there's lots of branches.
It's okay,
but it doesn't compare to like Italian food,
like Italian cuisine,
like the depth of Italian cuisine,
like German food is like,
it's,
you know,
it's okay.
It's amazing that it's very cut and dry ethnic food data that states will
fucking delicious Italian food every night than any other.
It's all comfort food.
I mean,
think of what Italian food is.
It's all pastas.
Lasagna is in meat sauce and it's all just comfort.
Can Delicious.
Yeah.
It's the best spaghetti and meatballs that this is something about the,
the,
the whole culture then that comes out of,
you know,
it says a lot about how the people that live in,
like it's,
it's healthy,
but you know the fuck it's not,
it's not made for health.
It's made for taste.
My lights.
One of the nights I would love to be home because to mylight those fucking
guineas,
they'd do it right.
My friends in Jersey,
they do it right though.
They do it the night of the seven Mars,
the seven fish,
seven fucking fish.
You've got to seven and it starts with those skinny little,
little,
uh,
what's the smelts and bonus.
Then they go to the clams,
then they go to the muscles.
Then they go to the fucking our shrimp.
Then they go and look at their clan and they put the crowd.
I miss.
I Miss Sausage and peppers,
peppers,
sub fry wanted for breakfast.
I get old down here.
Cavarretta.
Yeah,
it with tomato sauce.
They have a boss.
That's how they do it out here,
you know it's good.
It's great.
It's delicious.
I'm happy just to have,
this morning I was like the fried kind to right from yoga.
Me and my wife went my sausage and peppers,
beginner yoga at eight 30 how many points is that a million others?
That sausage and peppers.
I think I gave it like 14 I had the small so I had done a lot of points.
A sick one sausage one slash 92 but weight watchers changed the point system and
fat people are fucking it arms me.
I just stuck to the old points cause that's all I liked the new points.
I'll see if I can understand them.
I don't fucking understand what pretty much the new point systems now you can
eat as much vegetables and fruits which I did.
I did.
I never counted my points on fruit anyway but they doubled up on the pasta and
shit.
What a mixed sense.
Like there was some like there was too many like like like you should not be
allowed to eat like two point a cheese.
It's all day.
You know like you should not be able to do that.
There was things like that like,
like it just hadn't been updated in so long.
Guys you gotta explain if you're talking about this,
you gotta explain what the fuck the saw means.
Watch his watchers is a point based system.
It's usually,
it used to be based mostly on calories,
diet,
Terry Fat,
our fiber and fat grams and until five book at least the point.
Right?
Right.
You add up all the elements,
all the vegetables you want,
all the,
yeah.
I never counted them.
My points with vegetables or fruit because I knew it was a scam.
It's all water scan and I was right.
They just with the new system is way more accurate system.
Recent findings that goes,
we'll fucking and milk one of those little cheese that come with the inlet thing
like uh,
like a triangle or a blue Muga Moodle blue fucking pu one point.
Those cheeses.
Yeah.
We're fear crackers.
That's three points.
I'm full on one of the fucking pants that delicious.
You come home at night from doing a gate.
I don't have to eat a big meal no more.
I eat an apple on a piece of cheated points.
You get a day in just 30 days.
Diner is based on your whatnot.
It's based on your weight and height though my points aren't as high is 50 those
little chose cheese to fuck up my holder.
The cod new booze or something blue,
but they got blue cheese and switched the two for $6 a fucking routes.
I get to kill a week.
I you want a day in between meals.
Delicious.
There's so many little things,
but to every calorie is a for every,
for every 60 calories.
It's a point.
Okay.
So like when I go to the gym and work on the bike,
let's say I burned 600 calories on the bike at six points.
So now you can eat all the fruit and vegetables you want.
Right?
The new system is could,
but I always did,
which is how it should be a big shot because cause in the past it used to be
like,
fuck,
I'm so hungry.
I only have four points left.
I'm just going to eat two of these,
uh,
you know,
two points,
snicker bars or something like that.
Like it should have been like,
oh no,
I'm gonna just get you a bunch of vegetables and fruit and not have to worry
about that.
I'm hungry.
You know,
you should be allowed to do that.
That's how it should have been.
Anyways.
Every week I go,
I go to the farmer's market is I get strawberries or blueberries and
raspberries.
I've got a cantaloupe,
I gotta find out by chop up my putting containers and you eat.
If you're more than 300 pounds,
you got to eat more than we got to eat fruit seven times a day to lose weight
seven times a day.
You gotta eat fruit to lose fucking weight.
Really now the sugar from fruit,
it's not bad for you.
Not like the sugar that you put.
Well,
let me tell you something.
Is it because it's attached to fiber?
Custom Natural Shit.
It's,
I mean like is not bad for you eating a shitload of shit.
Yeah.
Brilliant.
Six cans of coke.
It's probably worse to have a diet coke than a regular Brian as always scared
the shit out of me because Brian knows always fucking putting down those
packages when I have coffee.
Like I'm always scared all equal and all that shit.
Yeah.
And so now I read,
I read,
I read last week that fucking sugar isn't really that bad feeling 10 days ago.
That said is the amount that you have in a day that's bad for you.
It's not that that day.
You know,
if you have 16 cups of coffee with 16 tablespoons,
oh sugar,
it's gonna fucking kill you.
You know?
You know what sucks is how popular rainbows are lately.
There was a double rainbow yesterday in Burbank and that was at staples and all
the,
and everyone ran
outside to take photos of it and I'm sitting here going,
I just need to check out.
I'm late.
I need to,
I need to.
There was nobody in the store and they're all going double rainbow will come out
as either people coming up.
Hey man,
it's just like you just can appreciate nature,
man.
It's like,
maybe you need to fucking relax,
man.
Well,
all this bull shit that you see here,
this is men made.
All right.
The real beauty is in nature.
It doesn't matter man,
whether or not you fucking get checked out in time,
right here is the Spooner.
Therefore,
oh,
now I'm looking at a Stevia.
I was just sad it.
Yeah,
but it's like before that video props to Dan Quinn,
before that video,
there was no like freaking out on rainbows.
I thought it was like,
oh look a rainbow there.
Now it's like people running outside to take photos of it for their Twitter just
to get goddamn sheep.
Brian,
it's like we were talking about earlier with about Liberia.
People get used to things being a certain way and then that's the way they are
to where they are now.
When you see a rainbow,
you freak out and uh,
if you live in Portland,
Oregon,
you seen a rainbow every day.
Your life like,
yeah,
no,
the one,
whatever.
It's fucking constantly raining.
You see a rainbow or we pay your fucking life.
I'm going to run outside.
It was weird though with that rainbow yesterday I was the closest I ever thought
I got to the actual end of a rainbow.
Like I don't think it's Paul Leprechaun.
No,
I don't think it's possible to,
can you get to an end of a random,
I don't think it is.
It's like an optical illusion,
right?
Of course.
But there was,
this was the first time where I actually was like,
dude,
it looks like it's right there.
The end of it.
And it was like a trader Joe's.
It moves as you move oil oil,
like in a desert type thing or you know,
we'll waste human waste is,
I mean maybe perhaps,
but it was so weird because like it looked like literally like on the other side
of this building is the end of the rainbow.
I've never seen it that close before it was fucked up.
Hmm.
Maybe here ever chased a rainbow baby.
Everyone just doesn't know Brian.
And maybe there is some rainbows that are different than other rainbows and when
you get to the end of them,
you find gold.
So I heard,
and you have to fight a Leprechaun.
I heard somebody got a higher primate tattoo that posted on the forum.
Some dude on a,
on my Facebook page,
he's got a higher primate,
a tattoo,
by the way,
those t shirts,
I it or they're coming out with new designs,
right.
Or something's coming up.
We got to watch a new show coming up.
I,
that was one of my favorite tee shirts,
like the one that I have.
I love that t shirt.
It's like fits perfect and everything.
This is really not that terrible.
It's just the eyeballs are a little off,
but he can fix that easy.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
It's um,
it's a good good that they're really cool man.
The guys who designed them,
they're bad ass.
Yeah,
we've got some new shit coming out.
We've got one coming out with Shiva gonna work on that one.
Powerful Higher Primary Sheba.
I'm branching out son.
I sold over a dozen of them shirts.
I'm a goddamn entrepreneurial maneuvers.
Some dude sent me this email.
Hey Man,
um,
uh,
I want you to consider stop saying Cock sucker cause you stopped saying faggot.
Now I'd like you to consider to stop saying cock sucker,
but all I could think of was you.
I'm like,
how am I going to do my Joey Diaz impression if I can't say Cock sucker?
I'm going home.
What the fuck?
Cock sucker.
I don't understand.
Look,
there's nothing wrong with sucking a cock and it's not,
it's not even a,
a bad thing.
You know,
I mean if you want to suck cock,
you should suck a cock.
It's like if you,
if someone called you a pussy eater,
it's really the same thing.
Would I feel bad?
You calling me a pussy eater?
Shut up.
It's done.
Ball Cock sucker like that.
Call it more as the expression.
It's an exactly.
It doesn't immediately expression of love.
When I call you a cock sucker,
if I don't call you,
then you should really think about what your fucking stand.
Joey Diaz will call me anytime of the night and go what's going on?
Cock sucker.
If I wore khaki liquor,
sometimes it's a cock liquor.
Sometimes it's cotton like cause sometimes we're going to calm.
You got to sweet.
I don't take none of that shit.
It's nothing wrong.
It's nothing wrong with it.
I know that sometimes it annoys people but it's only been a derogatory statement
but it's still like I am.
If you're talking about in the show,
you're talking about an act to talking about sucking a cock and it's not even a
bad person or nothing.
We can't keep making.
That's not the solution.
The solution is not say less things.
The solution is be nicer,
is that the solution is not stopped saying cock sucker.
That's silly.
You're,
you're missing the whole fucking point.
You should be able to sell,
say anything.
The only reason why you don't say anything because a bunch of people or a bunch
of fucking sensitive constantly.
You can't just keep explaining yourself over and over and over and over and over
again.
We live in a very politically correct society.
Half of us,
the other half a wild fucks like me.
And you know what?
This Day's I listened to,
I listened to a cat podcast and the guy has his white as a Republican and as
tight as he could be.
Blind joy.
You don't curse at all.
And I enjoy him.
Well I don't,
you don't care to things interested in what you're saying.
Yeah.
I don't like cock sucker.
Go hang out with fucking Gaffigan or something like that.
I don't give a fuck where you go hang out.
Here's the deal.
We all know there's a bunch of different words and we can,
yeah,
they just want use whatever words you want.
What I want to know is who are you as a human and if you,
you know,
if you're judging someone by the words they're using and not judging them by who
they are,
you know,
come on man,
like really you care if a guy swears you care if the guy you know talks about
certain subjects that you know might be a bit controversial when you get people
that are like super sensitive about shit like that and it's just like,
come on man,
what's the point in even talking?
I have never left the place even though I've had a bad experience with it and I
don't think it's time.
I don't think no places worth going home and writing a letter.
I went to a restaurant last week that was fucking horrible.
Why that we know whose fault it was.
Mine that I didn't go to the usual want.
I think shit like Yelp.
If you've had some bad situations and you know you can go to like Yelp and you
look and there's like a one star,
how many times did you go to college?
Don't you walk to the back to get your check and they gave you a,
handed you a letter and you're like,
what's this?
And there's a letter of fan row that you would sell to somebody.
You could,
you said the word con cock sucker.
If you're going to go home and write a letter,
because I said something,
honest to God,
I don't think you have a fucking life.
I have bad experiences and a lot of times I went to home buffet bird back two
weeks to go,
well,
this is that again.
I was starving.
Applebee's
was passed.
I went shopping in that more there and I go,
how bad?
His hometown buffet.
Oh,
Helen worsening or you get a salad and you can't get a fucking salad somewhere,
right Brian,
when I tell you the salad dressings,
the salad was brown and why wouldn't you be able to,
why he,
shouldn't he be able to talk about this on a Yelp ad?
[inaudible] fucking going there.
I'm an adult.
I'm a fucking adult.
I know better.
I say to people,
here's why.
When people come up to me,
especially people who live in California,
especially you two fucking mobiles.
We didn't come up to me as somebody.
You went to see a movie.
I want to stab yours because you see behind the curtain [inaudible] just want to
go to the movies and then you just watch that movie the other day.
That was awful.
What was the one we were just talking
at the beginning of the podcast you watched a Riley or though what?
The movie he said he was watching at the beginning of the podcast.
You watched a movie the other day and it was awful.
I don't remember this.
I didn't say that,
but I didn't watch the whole movie.
That title.
The island of Doctor Moreau.
Oh No,
no book of Eli.
I took you off in 15 minutes.
I didn't get my stuff.
No,
I would never take somebody else's opinion.
Listen,
if you went to see that,
if you went to see that fucking movie with Angelina Jolie and that other fucking
Momo who I love Donnie Brasco,
you're a fucking idiot.
And you left there and said,
that wasn't what I thought it was.
You should be shot on that thrown under the jail and then fucked in the ass by a
bunch of runaway fucking slaves because you're a fucking idiot.
Donnie BRASCO.
Hey,
go see where they have slaves,
where they have slaves anywhere.
This lays around,
they really Houston,
they got those little Chinese women,
they bring in these things and they got to pay money to get their uncle out of
fucking whatever.
If a gradation status and some shit you're gonna see now fucking CSM,
the drifters repeat girls in Houston.
You have,
what's that called?
The,
uh,
human trafficking.
Human trafficking is very big in Houston.
Very big in a couple of them.
So you think they should get fucked by human traffickers?
If they,
what if,
what movie they do,
they like any movie that you go see,
you will,
like,
I read a Twitter the other day.
I went to see tron.
It was horrible.
What would make you go see that fucking movie?
I saw tron.
It was Terry liked it.
He liked it.
I think it was that bad.
It was kind of interesting.
Why would you go see that movie for the Three d three d?
The whole concept to me was fast.
If you got really baked Joey and you saw a three d movie might be awesome.
It'd be like,
because I don't let stuff from me.
It might be for you.
You like pay for the wall.
The only thing that was really,
wow,
I didn't like pink Floyd.
The Wall.
The movie.
I like pink Floyd.
The Wall alive too.
Yeah.
Wear Three d glasses.
Did you see Troy and Brian?
No,
I,
I'm waiting for the madness to die down a little bit for to see half of those
shit movies and people realize that three Ds,
the Shit I to see her at.
Woah.
What the fuck is fun,
man?
Listen Dude.
It's just like watching the God damn comic book to me.
I liked comic books.
I liked him when I was a kid.
I love your comic book movie and that's what our trauma was a comic book movie
comic books of telling you you like comic books.
Fuck yeah.
I used to,
I used to be into the fantastic four.
I had a place,
Bobby something.
He used to collect things and we used to go up there by comic books from the
rob,
the good ones and take them to the city and Xcel.
Well Bobby,
they call off one of these things.
I like things that aren't realistic.
I think they're fun.
You know,
I don't mind her to the suspension of disbelief or comic book movie doesn't me.
I love to be taken away for two hours,
but tron don't take me away the whole time.
I'm thinking,
why the fuck that I come to this shit?
Because if the weed store buying a bag of dope or something,
he kept me occupied.
It wasn't,
we said,
go see half of you more than listen bro.
That hangover that you people think is fucking great.
I watched it and it was Robert Stevens is an admin.
It was no pleasant movie.
It was fun as it was.
No,
it was no fight,
wasn't it bro,
please.
Because there's nothing to put up next to it.
That's why there's nothing going on.
There was an auto,
I enjoyed it.
It was the old cable.
It nothing was night.
There was just not a groundbreaking subject.
A bunch of guys get fucked up and what did we do last night?
I mean it's not,
but I thought it was well executed.
Were Shitty fucking society.
That's weak and that's why these movies go over now.
They wouldn't go over 20 years ago when you hide,
had a higher quality of movies,
Bro.
These movies wouldn't fucking go on with that new one.
That Fokker three looks like.
Aw.
Oh,
the third Fokker movie.
That is a second form diarrhea right there.
One of my idols that got me into this whole thing was when I seen dia hunter,
well that scene fucking taxi driver and I seen De,
they put that gun to his head and do all that shit.
I knew I was going to end up here,
but de Niro,
you got to stop it and stop Saturday night live to top it suck at Saturday
night.
I'll fucking hard anymore.
And the choices you're making,
you might as well do one Janya and shoot yourself with movies.
Tales of Jonathan.
Just shoot your hands and Janya peep into what?
What's a shot?
Fake Narnia to quilting.
Quilting.
I don't want to really did he wrote I love you to death but let it go.
He said it was going to character from
that.
What was that?
Narnia movie chronicles and Janya.
Whatever the fuck they got Narnia yanking out will revise.
Do when they tell me what it is Brian.
Yeah.
Shit.
Chronicles of Narnia.
No,
but he wasn't in there.
he was the other one.
He was,
he was only Michelle Pfeiffer.
Insists in the phone.
Fucking some shit.
I would watch that if you fucking held a gun to my head.
Just cause I got better things to do with my fucking time.
So,
um,
why would you watch that?
I'm done with him and I'm also done with,
um,
you know what's weird,
and this is off subject completely off subject,
but I want to know what that movie was.
Chronicles of young Ya.
Let me tell you something.
First One star dust if you've heard.
That's it.
I'll read this.
Lee Bad with Michelle.
Oh my God.
The movie theater that came up that came out a Friday at 1130 and it got
released.
This looks like some shit that was made,
but he got like,
so Saudi Arabian trillionaire like royal family member.
Listen,
this is what we're going to have.
We're going to have ancient time [inaudible] coming in.
What about the radicals of God?
Yeah.
Not at all.
Chronic [inaudible] made like this is something different,
man.
This is the star dust stewards in it.
Read the cast.
Did they wrote Michelle Pfeiffer.
Oh,
I don't know.
Let's see.
And they tried to get pachino for Scarface,
Rudy and on Ganja for that.
Whatever that shows those two on this by somebody else in that movie too.
It so gross star dust.
That Green Horn,
it looks fucking bad too.
Ah,
that looks,
aw.
Carl's junior commercial.
Ah,
Bruce Lee is in his grave making a comeback after he seen that fucking piece of
shit.
That's a piece of shit.
The kid didn't even know what the fuck it's about,
so let's just,
why the fuck are we doing?
What do you mean the kid didn't know that fucking Monster Green fucking Horn
Oregon.
That was nothing.
And they got some fucking Filipino to pay Bruce Lee.
I've got nothing against Filipino and my people,
you know what I'm saying?
But the guy was fucking Chinese.
You know what I'm saying?
Have you guys seen that musical,
that tray and Matt are doing in New York City?
It opens like next month.
It's a musical about Mormons.
It's called like,
oh no,
dude.
One of,
one of my favorite things about Trey and Matt,
the guys that did South Park is that their musicals,
like they,
you know,
South Park was physical and he's had mechanical,
the movie musical and stuff.
This is a whole play based on Mormons and it's a musical.
Fucking
no star does got 7.9 stars.
Yeah,
out of 10.
right.
I'm going to buy it.
Buy It.
You're going to be calling.
Hi.
Good.
Ian Mcclellan's in it.
Yeah,
that's good.
And they came with the long cash.
They got Ian,
Robert De Niro,
Michelle Pfeiffer,
Charlie Cox,
Kate McGowan.
Respectable people in this.
I wonder who they got first that the connected everybody else too.
Probably Deniro.
We have Robert De Niro.
This was a good movie.
What about the spider man playing with beautiful.
That's a fuck
about that.
Oh,
what's his name that did that?
Twitter.
And he got in trouble for saying it.
Ah,
fuck.
What's his name?
He said something.
Did you hear about the Spiderman guy?
There's a play on a Spiderman play.
Yeah.
Didn't,
aren't people get in?
Oh yeah.
This,
this stunt man fell four times and they got bottle and the other fucking mobile.
The storm,
you know whole.
You guys will get to Julie Taymor.
We're going to pull this off.
First of all,
it's a billion a week to keep the doors open.
Yeah.
So what do you kind of,
let me kick it through on 60 minutes,
three weeks ago,
publicized it.
$1 million for production a week for a play in New York City.
What is this?
This is Spiderman.
The play.
What the fuck are they doing?
Just because Bono,
God,
you mean Bono and the stall and rewrote it.
Wait a minute,
I bought,
I know like the guy from u two he wrote this play.
We live in a Coen brothers movie.
We fucking do man.
Listen to what you said.
There is a fucking play and involves Spiderman and that's on Broadway and it
cost $1 million a week.
The bottom of the yeah.
Bottle and the storm wrote the music for it and they've had four shutdowns.
Hooray for poor people fall down because she wants to do like a thing where it's
a plague.
So do they do flips and shit,
brings people flying across lights,
but it's gonna cost or do so on a Tuesday night to go see this and this economy,
a million dollar production now at the five people fall in and all of the
setbacks,
they're still like,
it's going to go on
creative lost Damon Lindelof or whatever his name said with great power comes.
Great response.
Wow,
Pam,
crash stinging.
You know,
he said that and I guess the stuntmen that did that,
it's like in serious condition may never walk again or something like that.
So we got a shitload of heat and so he wrote,
he retweeted the,
uh,
last night.
I had no idea to start.
It was so injured,
seriously injured,
bad tastes aren't as regards and hopefully a speedy recovery.
But he got,
oh fuck.
Like people were pissed at him for that tweet.
It's funny how tweets nowadays you can just say at twit and it could change your
whole career.
Who was,
who was really,
yeah,
you could say so douchey.
This is like watching CNN show Biz report.
They're like,
listen,
come back with everybody's talking about who's talking about it.
What?
Fuck at Bob off talking about the stats better.
The guy that he twitted okay.
Talking about this.
Who told them?
Who gives a fuck?
I give a fuck.
They were talking about why are we mind that talking about on TMZ,
people fucking stuck in some,
all of the ric cave at talking about it cause they got nothing better to do in a
jail cell.
People with lives don't give a fuck.
People with bills and mortgages don't give a fuck.
That's the book.
The book of Mormon that's there.
Uh,
the new musical.
Yeah.
When does it come out?
New York City at previous February 24th opens March 24th.
But
those guys are awesome.
God,
they're alive.
I know.
For Real,
nobody has entertained me more than the South Park guys over over the course of
their,
their careers.
No one,
no one even comes close.
Those guys have been putting out for over a decade.
Strong.
Yeah.
It was like when I first heard about them,
I worked first watched the Brian Boitano.
What would Brian Boitano do that was like,
shit that was like,
it seems like that was like 98 or something like that.
Yeah.
That was so long ago.
It's a long ass time ago.
It seems like when I saw it,
it was somewhere around then.
Yeah.
What would Brambleton it might even been before 98 man,
cause I think I was living in Encino.
Are you playing what?
Luke?
Brian Boitano do a little bit crazy.
I did that.
Fuck these guys will.
Yeah.
Which movie did you do?
Good Ball?
No.
Did I give a fuck?
Oh yeah,
that's right.
You were in your like guy.
You have no idea what he fought in the body guy.
He played one in the road.
They cool.
Okay.
Yeah.
No,
I mean fuck they're bad motherfuckers,
man.
I'd be very happy.
Yeah.
Well you know what happened,
especially after that Carlos was here episode
[inaudible] how old school?
I might not only be [inaudible]
say my name,
we'll get you and you little that you got like nothing.
Just Maxon and relaxing,
kicking back a bone on tackling and low.
What are you doing with John Lovitz?
Delay in the mall for me.
Baseball is a couple of other guys that were saying one tonight and tomorrow.
Yeah,
we'll damn,
you're doing a Christmas eve show.
Damn.
It's not crazy at that universal get there early and 12.
Let me tell you something.
Last year,
fucking uh,
they said that last Christmas Eve will last.
No,
no.
Gabriel did last Christmas Day.
He did four shows.
The last show he took everybody and he had about two oh five in the morning.
Gene Simmons included.
You had the whole play.
Took them all out to eat every live show.
Everybody.
He took the whole crown out to eat three,
four of that fucking Holy Shit.
Have where?
Where the fuck did they fit?
Everybody is up in daddy's somewhere and they fit everybody in.
Yeah.
Wow.
We'll half the people went home.
Fucking,
he took that soul areas fucking nuts.
That's hilarious.
So it's,
they said it's gonna be crazy.
You're gene Simmons.
Gene Simmons is a big comedy Fan,
Huh?
Yes.
For new episodes coming out on fish show,
by the way,
who?
Just Gene Simmons for new episodes about what I know is his reality show show.
You Watch it.
No,
I don't watch.
I just saw today I've been watching celebrity Rehab at Eddie Bravo's
recommendation and my God,
is it good?
Yeah.
It's the best.
Don't get into that show.
This isn't even a good one.
Oh,
it's plenty.
This isn't even a good season.
Yeah.
Hear about any of the [inaudible] Andy Dick was on.
Oh,
you list a good.
So this is a bad lived with any tech for five years.
It's not lived with him,
but we're good enough.
I don't need to see that show.
I hope Andy's,
we were just talking about a hundred grand for 21 days.
They're they to heal you to let me tell you something,
man.
This,
this episode's getting me man or this,
this season's get me if this isn't a good one.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You got to say is Eric Roberts is fucking fine.
Okay.
Eric Roberts is surrounded by these maniacs and nuts and all.
He's hooked on his weed.
Yeah.
Okay.
So every day people are going through dts there,
shake lifeguards.
Try and fucking fix.
He's like,
I gotta get Outta here.
Meanwhile,
Eric Roberts has got his reading glasses on.
Is Drinking a cup of coffee looking through the paper like a gentlemen.
There is nothing wrong with that guy,
Eric Roberts.
If you're out there,
if you're listening,
listen to me,
man.
You don't need to stop smoking weed.
You just need better people to smoke weed with.
That's what your problem is.
You're freaking out.
You're by yourself.
Okay.
What about that Billy?
The kid or the kid?
That poor kid.
Man,
that poor kid is in a terrible situation.
We,
he's raised by some fucking cut bag that didn't pay attention to them and it's
the dad was never knows.
I like last season.
It's sucks,
man.
It sucks.
But you know,
that's how you raise a shitty kid.
I'll be digging for a mess,
man.
You could tell suck.
Oh,
I bet she's going to tell me.
She's gonna say she looks like she's flushes water dirty.
What about the model?
You know,
she,
her eyebrows were freaking me the fuck out them eyebrows were not where they're
supposed to be.
John.
It was driving me nuts.
Well,
they're not drawn on man.
They're just pulled up way up.
She's not that old man.
She's a young girl and she's pretty enough.
Like she doesn't have to keep fucking with herself.
It's like girls,
they get to a certain point where tronic continually tweak things.
Like you got to realize that any guy who would give a fuck about those minute
differences that you're trying to sort out in your face,
that guy's a douche bag or shoes.
Yeah,
they would come by just fucking let it go.
So you're going to get a line in your forehead.
We're all going to die.
You're going to be fun.
But that fucking line grown you,
your about the line.
The kid dropped last week.
This may appear line of wall
time on a reality show.
What?
It was an argument that in a kid actor from the hills goes,
I've been in a rehab.
I'd never seen anything like that.
I've never seen anything like this.
Eight rehabs.
And you're still trying fucking move kid.
He's like 25 rehabs.
Eight we had,
you haven't figured out.
Fuck it.
I'm balls on prop out old oldest,
that dude and he's been to eight
rehabs,
three rehabs.
I went to one because they made me go in a halfway house because I came back
half away.
Cocaine as it goes through your skin when you wait on the scale.
Oh,
so I came back hot.
So I said to you,
we put you back in jail for six months or you have to go to a rehab and I found
as a rehab in boulder that all you had to do was go from two to six and you'd be
healed in four weeks.
Ah,
boulder ate it right up and leave.
You're going to go to and they want to like a grand and that's it.
And had to go from two to six and I would go down,
I got a little chick that was there.
Her name was Patrice twining from Michigan.
She was sucking my Dick every afternoon during the break,
like from two to four and then for Florida for 20 we can have a cigarette break
and she'd suck my Dick.
I do align with her at the fucking thing.
I appreciate that.
I appreciate Rehab for some people and I think we both know people that just
cannot do things.
They just,
whatever the fuck it is where they do a bump or they smoke a joint or they do a
shot,
they are going to go off on a goddamn blackout adventure of death.
And
here's the real problem.
And you know this because you have an addictive personality to games and pool,
and we've discussed this
say gays or games.
It's really weird and Brian knows as we've all discussed this,
but he was going to
go to 50 fucking rehabs and unless you're ready to quit,
you ain't going to quit.
Yeah,
it doesn't.
You know,
here's the,
here's the bail issue,
here's right,
here's the real issue.
They're not using all of the best methods that are available.
It's very simple.
If you look throughout human history as the number one most effective way to get
over in addiction,
it's Ibogaine.
I bill gained the super psychedelic drug that's illegal in America.
People have taken that stuff and it's got some insane rate of,
of healing.
People from addictions like ruin the 90% and you're talking about when you're
talking about 90% of people that are addicted like God,
and a lot of them have to go back to the same environment.
A lot of people are impulsive,
but it's such an insanely introspective
experience.
You see all of your wiring and where things are going wrong.
Why were the wrong connections?
We don't allow any eyeopening shit.
You know why?
Because it makes no money.
Because if we did that,
there'd be no rehab.
You know we're going to wait.
Well,
no,
it's not even that.
It's like you can't,
and here's the funny thing about weight watchers.
It's a corporation for you to lose weight,
but they don't want you to lose weight Guy Guy.
It's not that they don't want to heal you.
They haven't thought about it this far in advance.
It's that there's no money in the cure.
I began whatever it is,
it's,
it grows.
It's the same thing like marijuana.
It's 4,000 for the treatment to get the on the doctor in your room with the
blood pressure to check your blood pressure,
the street days of sweating and psychedelic logical trips and we'll whole thing.
We can open up rehabs where people go into that page 8,000 and get,
he'll never have to go back,
but the rehabs that around the open now they get money from repeat business.
They want you to get healthy,
but they don't really want you to get healthy.
The FDA really pat,
I really believe it.
I think I really evolved and treatment or trying to help people.
I really do that.
Try to help people.
They really are trying to help Brian out,
but the fucking odds,
the recidivism rate,
I don't think they know about Ibogaine.
I think there's a very small percentage of the people that are involved in any
addictive behavior counseling.
Like,
you know,
like if you look at like,
like doctor drew,
like he doesn't even don't even consider a psychedelic drug trip to cure you of
addictions.
He would never consider it if you,
but hold on a second.
If you look at it on paper,
if you'll get the people that have actually experienced these things,
like it looks like there's something there and it looks like it was not just
like with actual studies they've done on everything.
I read about it as very popular thing.
I read about it positive.
If I come to you right now and say,
Joe Rogan,
guess what?
You're not going to have to ever go on the road and do comedy no more.
We're going to build this stage right here and you're going to do comedy on
this,
a new system and we're going to do comedy at the computer and people don't even
eat to leave the house anymore to leave the house.
Or you don't get to watch county,
right?
Watch comedy from the House alive.
Well,
this is sort of an extension of that is going to take,
well,
oh,
now you're not seeing where I'm going with that.
That's going to take a piece of money out of your pocket.
It is.
If I started,
if I avoided comedy clubs and just started doing thing on the computer and
people could see if the free and you couldn't tour that.
That's what I'm trying to say to you.
If they'd bring this Ibogaine in,
you're only going to come to my rehab one time and get healed.
The percentage rates are going to be lower,
so you take the money out on my part.
I don't want to hit right.
I don't think that's the case.
I really don't.
I don't think that these rehab centers don't want to heal people and they want
to keep people.
I'm not saying that.
I don't think you know of reality and reality.
They know about it.
The FDA will not approve it.
Yes.
With 10 until the FDA approves it.
They won't do it 10 years away,
2015 years away from the FDA approved it,
but it's because they found in his seventies like Carl Sagan talked openly about
how easily marijuana would be legal within a decade.
They were like,
it was just inevitable.
It's not going to be legal for another two or three years is
will not get marijuana.
Yeah.
Well No,
I don't.
I don't even believe that anymore after this stupid law.
If he can't pass in California,
come on man.
This is the,
if you don't,
this is the law.
The apex of the information age was,
it was like sloppy was completely,
completely thrown together.
Sloppy.
Oh,
it's like their way through ignorance.
There was like a bunch of things like that law would have pass it so it was
legal to smoke weed at work,
you know,
as an example and stuff like it was just thrown together really bad.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's what a lot of people who are against it.
We have to look this up.
You can't say this unless we know for sure that that's one of the things I know,
but we have to be careful.
[inaudible] have to be care.
Society to hit say promises in 19 position 19 there was things like that thrown
in there,
like multiple things just like that that were thrown in there,
that were just sloppy and even people that wanted that,
the legalize marijuana,
they didn't like it because it was just fucking thrown together bad.
But if anything it showed that it was,
you know,
the next time it's on,
if they have some more time to write it better and stuff like that,
it probably will pass.
I think it was that the growers were saying don't vote.
Yeah,
well go into pot shop.
You're going to have hot shots.
People would say not to vote for her because then they would go under.
That would be the problem said.
First of all,
no one would have,
you wouldn't have to go to these places to buy your pod.
We wouldn't have to be licensed.
Not necessarily because these are medical place.
11 totally different reason for selling.
You can't mix the medical places with,
you know,
with places that are just for profit.
Only the,
I'm sure you would have to have different laws that it'd be,
but wow.
Pot-Smoking at work.
Glue Group claims his true.
That's the dumbest Shit I've ever heard.
By the way saying this,
this law was stupid.
I mean it was,
it was sloppy and stupid.
That's why I didn't pass.
It wasn't a good written law.
Somebody was,
somebody was stone when they wrote that law.
They didn't think it out.
You know,
the California Chamber of Commerce claimed in legal analysis released Thursday.
Their proposition 19 would lead to more workplace accidents by forcing employers
to let workers smoke pot on the job.
See these fucking greedy stoners.
You greedy.
It's a retarded.
Oh my God,
that's amazing.
I thought that that had to be wrong.
I was like,
I bet he's got it.
Like,
Oh,
if it's a job that you don't operate,
I love you man.
God,
come on faith,
dude.
I do have faith,
but occasionally we both know you sick.
You say some crazy shit.
It's occasionally,
don't,
you know,
never to go.
All this stuff.
I say there's,
there's some truth to it.
I'm like Alex Jones to dog toto.
I saw Alex go into co raising the other day.
I saw some fucking thing.
We were talking about deep population.
So it's happened and it's all going on.
Just one of just go grab the guy and go get him a drink.
Come on.
Did you ever see him dressed up as the joker?
No.
Youtube that Alex Jones a joker.
He's dressed as the joker with like the blood on as much to talk about Alex,
because the video is coming out this week.
Right?
We're going to have it done this week.
I love Alex Jones.
Like people
think,
oh,
Joe Rogan is logos.
Jones thinks I was chosen.
Idiot.
That I love that guy.
He's fun.
He's my friend Izzy,
right?
I don't know.
It's all right.
Oh look,
I got more important things to think about.
I'm worried about the universe.
Okay,
ladies.
Gentlemen.
I'm worried about aliens,
which I worked for NASA.
Fuck,
okay.
I'm worried about really,
really interesting things to me.
Whether or not Alex Jones is right about everything.
That's interesting as well.
I mean this,
the study of the human race to the fall of room,
seeing all this crazy shit go on,
seeing how much of it is just nonsense and crazy talk like they're going to put
chips in your cornflakes and it's gonna,
you know,
come on.
How much is that real?
I don't know.
But I do know he's right about a lot of things.
There's a lot of shit going on,
man.
We're seeing,
we're seeing much more exposure of all the corruption in all levels of
government.
You know,
much more exposure than anybody that ever had access to before and the
government doesn't give a fuck that we know.
Yeah,
they don't give a fuck.
They cannot do anything about doing.
No,
we can't.
You know,
think about Alex Jones is that he's great and he exposes us to a lot of things
and some of it is useful.
Some of it isn't.
At the end of the week,
there's nothing we could do about it.
There's not much we could do it by them because nobody's going to even fucking
get together.
The sign not going to put none together.
Here's reality,
here's reality and this is where it's going to get sound really strange.
This is what we can do about it.
There's not no,
there's nothing we can do about it.
[inaudible] as far as going out and I mean look,
Obama thought he was going to change things,
so I have many gotten the office guy wins the fucking Nobel prize then sends
30,000 more troops to Afghanistan if he really thought that he was going to be
able to do anything differently.
Once you get in an office,
once you get in there,
you kind of understand you're dealing with a machine that is just fucking beyond
your comprehension,
so intertwined with corruption,
but this is what you can do well you can do is what we're doing well you can do
is with anybody out there who's doing,
who's showing a more positive example and giving you a more fun and happy way to
live your life.
You inspire people to potentially live along those same lines and that's what
you can do and that's what you could do with art and that's what you could do
with writing and that's what you could do with any form of expression.
And that's what you can do if you express yourself and let people know that
that's how you're living and this is the fun way to do it,
man.
You don't have to be a con.
You don't have to be a Douche bag.
You don't have to be out there raping the world,
like that's not the right way to go about it.
It's not fun.
You just need a lot of people to recognize that vision and see it and realize,
hey,
we are only here for a short amount of time.
If you go around saying it's all about me living like life,
like a fucking Douche bag,
when it's all over,
you're going to have just a wreck of a life.
You're not going to be enjoying yourself.
You're not going to be having a good time through this fucking thing.
If we can all recognize that we really could put this place in a different
frequency,
we really could make human beings respond and behave on a better level than
we're doing now.
The only way that we're going to do it is to electrify the young.
You've got to,
you got to get in their head.
You've got to inspire these people.
There's people out there that are hearing some of the shit that you're saying
this the shit that Brian's saying,
some shit that Duncan says on this podcast,
you're hearing all this shit and it's,
it's ringing in their mind.
They're hearing Eddie stories.
You know when he starts talking about Jujitsu and breaking down life and in
breaking down his own,
you know,
his own ability to figure out things and you know,
people hear about shit like that,
man.
It gets you thinking and you start questioning like,
how have I been managing my life?
If I've been doing the same thing,
I will now be inspired to manage my life in a similar fashion and live in a
happy,
positive way and don't get stuck in some fucking trap and don't think that this
thing is it permanent because it's not permanent.
If you go around live in like,
you know,
you could just keep,
keep up with this shit bag life and eventually some day you're going to get a
nap.
You know you're going to get a a point in your life where you can settle down
and relax with that points on fucking happen in man,
that's not gonna happen.
Shit begets shit and it's just gonna get worse because your health is going to
fail on you.
Keep it together.
Bitches very cheerful.
The re no,
it is a cheerful message because the reality is the only way to do it is to
really,
if you really want to change the world,
you have to inspire young people.
That's how you change the world.
The world isn't.
People that don't have mortgages.
The world is in people that can still create new things.
The world is in people that can still take chances because they don't have to
worry about coming home to take care of their kids.
The world is in chances,
man.
You could still inspire chances.
You can still inspire thinking.
It's still inspire positive energy.
Mad Flavor is all up in this bitch,
right?
The fuck you talking about?
Fuck,
I'm talking about an orange fucking suit on with goggles.
You.
You know what I'm talking about?
So my eyes,
you're fixing the world.
Joe Dixon,
a one guy at a time.
One tree at a time.
I got to compete with Paris Hilton.
You follow me?
Who?
I ain't doing shit for fucking nobody.
I'm not looking to save the world.
I'm just looking to get a few fucking labs,
smoke a few joints,
get healthy,
love my wife and my cats and be able to have a good time when I'm hanging out
with you.
Mother fuckers and part of doing that is inspiring other people.
Part of doing that is making other people laugh.
When you're doing that and you're inspiring people and making other people how
you are literally creating a better environment,
you're,
you're forcing people to be happier.
Not forcing them,
but you're helping people to be happier and you're moving them along in a good
direction.
That's the future.
That's the only way that we're really going to have a future.
We gotta work together.
Brian,
it's your move.
Uh,
do you that comic books now Brian's just gonna Masturbate watery sperm on is,
I'm going to Disneyland for Christmas belly.
I'm kind of nervous.
I've never been to Disney land.
Last time I was at Disney road was like 11 years old or something like that.
It's really fun when there's no one there.
Why would you want to go on a day?
What's going to be moms?
It's Disneyland.
Mamako Christmas I thought.
Yeah,
and what did the
bad,
really bad
stay the fuck.
Let's see.
If you want to go,
what you're supposed to do is go while the kids are in school.
You don't need to go on a special day son.
[inaudible] that hasn't really even Jesus's birthday.
Okay.
Jesus is born in June or some shit.
Right?
This is fake.
You get in the hotel room to now this is going to drive up and sunny,
say five minutes.
Pagans man,
it was their holiday.
It was the winter solstice man in like,
you know,
in order to get the Pagans to be Christians,
they combine holidays.
That's certainly don't go dude,
go on like a Tuesday day.
Yeah.
Do you want to get there early?
For some reason I thought it wouldn't be crowded.
Oh,
you're crazy.
Crazy is always crowded.
I heard two weeks ago is crowded on Saturday.
He said it was the most grounded he's ever seen in this fucking line.
You don't appreciate Disneyland until you have little kids.
Right?
Oh my God.
When I take my little daughter to Disneyland,
I have never had this much fun in my grown life that I can remember just taking
her around and just like getting on the tea cup rides and Deborah going to do
this ride.
Do Dutch like so excited at every turn,
like giant joyful smiles and you see these kids running around you go,
now I get it.
Yeah,
but I always thought of it as like,
it's a pain in the ass.
My parents are yelling at me,
don't go any way I can get out of here.
You know?
It's like I came here by myself when I was 10 and 11 and shit.
Really?
I used to come out of here.
My uncle would drop me off at Disneyland so low the fucking day out there and
fly back to New York a week later.
Wow.
Dot Yourself,
Huh?
God.
You meet friends there and fuck friends.
I was living in New Jersey.
I'm from New Jersey.
I'm going to fucking Disney land mugging kids in those days.
Yeah,
my snap dropped me off one time.
He's done candy canes out.
Then the next day he couldn't go,
so he just dropped me off.
I don't want to deal with like 100 bucks and I get to blow in the tea cups
and was not a small room for me.
You never seen anybody have fun?
You don't experience joy like joy through a little two year old,
that's your two year old and she's running around a park having a good time.
I'd ride like I totally understand that all now man.
I used to like,
look,
I swear to God,
I used to like look at people that had kids and look at the things that they
were doing with kids and I would say,
yeah,
you know,
hey look at this guy loves his kid and this wife loves her kid but now here they
are hanging out at Disneyland.
They don't want to be in fucking Disneyland like they want,
they want to be home.
I did.
I never really understood that.
When your children are having fun and they're laughing,
you like laugh with them,
you have fun with them.
I never kind of got that until I had kids.
You know what I mean?
So it's like I always said,
well you're happy for them.
Sure.
Like you know,
they'll look at the kid's happy.
Oh I'm happy to.
That's great.
But it's not that man,
it's your happy to,
you're with them.
You're like one of them.
Like when they get excited and jump around and laugh.
You get like this charge through your body.
It's like the furnace of,
of,
of whatever the fuck that's in you,
your soul,
your spirit is like the door opens to the furnace and like winds of pure oxygen
blow on it.
That's what it feels like.
It's like,
oh,
like everything fires up and it's like,
you just like have this insane feeling of love and happiness.
Watching these little kids have a good time laughing and joking around and
cackling and just having so much fun.
And you know,
putting on a little princess dress.
I am a princess.
I always thought that would be annoying.
But you don't realize it's not even a little annoying.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a crazy thing,
man.
I always say that having children is just like having mushrooms.
If you haven't done it,
shut the fuck up because you really don't know.
You really don't know.
Having children is a strange trip,
man.
So strange.
Plus every ever been around children and watch pink Floyd the wall anyway.
By the way.
Have you been to [inaudible] Jewish terrorist.com what is that?
It's a awesome web [inaudible] dot org I'm sorry,
I filthy Jew as terrorist.org is a great website.
One of my favorite websites,
and I just noticed that Ra Hsa fears on the front page of it.
He's a terrorist and then there's some sort of comedy.
No.
Is that racist?
Jew Ari Shaffir posing as a racist KKK.
Klansmen the Jews are the most vile racist creatures on the face of the earth.
Look at this joke going around the hood somewhere deep in the black neighborhood
in the inner city.
Ghetto deep in the United States of America that you attempted to pose like a
clan member while making races and Dr. Morgan Marks.
Rogatory yeah,
he thought were good for him though.
But anyways,
that's crazy.
I just thought,
wow,
belted you.
terrorists.org why don't we,
maybe we shouldn't want to promote that.
No,
I wouldn't promote it.
This is awful.
Oh fuck you doing man now always going to get all this hate mail.
I'm sorry.
My mom is the one that told me about this website.
It's great.
Yeah.
Don't tell worry about it.
All right?
Actually you have to tell them about it.
Now it's on the podcast.
You Fuck?
Oh,
how come you didn't tell him about it yet?
You decided to broadcast that shit all throughout the world that a bunch of
people who hate hate him.
Sorry,
Ari haters and you're giving them all this props.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you have any self control,
please do not go to that website.
Do not support these terrible people.
They need Jewish,
uh,
flashlights like a difference.
And plus I use a different kind of vagina that the Jew has teeth.
And how's Keith?
Stinky.
Whoa.
How many Jewish girls have you had sex with your whole life?
Told three.
Three,
three.
And how many of them stuck?
One.
One stunk.
And um,
did this,
this is one have a reason for stinking that you could discern.
I don't know.
She was just a Vegan.
Just always was like a dirty hippie at heart.
Now what it's think like did smell like a,
but just smelled like cheese poured.
Showering,
poor showering.
Okay.
No more comments.
More comments from Mr Reichel.
How rude.
I'll tell you what,
man,
I've done some kissing and tell you back in my day.
But what are you talking about?
Nice.
This was like 10 years ago.
I stopped.
This was 10 years ago.
I'll go when you realize it hurts their feelings.
This is a 10 years ago.
There's girl things to talk about.
Definitely.
I don't even know who this was in Ohio too is a different kind of smell that
they come from.
I know it's the cow milk or the milk.
The grass out there.
They're more,
they're more hardy.
They get more cow antibiotics and their diet.
Yeah.
The Fuck Joe D is,
look at him.
He's looking at me.
He's like,
you have this poor kid.
He's lost.
He's lost man.
Boy,
he's got his little Zack.
A man was Zack Calvin atmosphere.
Well,
they say that when,
um,
there's,
uh,
I think I got this right when there's not as many men around,
um,
men should start shaving their head,
their,
their face and start like getting more feminine.
But when there's a more men around,
men started growing facial hair.
Really?
Yeah.
So almost like to let all the men know that they have testosterone,
they grow the facial hair to let them know and when there's an abundance of
women and uh,
not that many men that men get all fucking girly,
they start shaving,
wearing Cologne and shit.
You Wear Cologne Joe Death.
I like fuck Outta here.
Right,
right.
That's what I'm talking about.
Give me some of that man that wears Cologne.
I don't trust.
I don't trust in me that hide and some,
especially if you wear some rappers colonial fuck a year as a tip.
Most girls that I've met,
I've met love Cologne.
They're the ones that buy it.
Here's a tip.
So give me on you broken bitches.
Yeah,
but I'm not trying to hit on you.
I don't care if you don't like the smell that,
that I spray on me.
But I spray one the spray and that girl smelled it nailed.
Those girls are broken or broken.
It's like shoes.
Like I don't give a fuck about shoes,
but if I buy a certain kind of shoe that I certainly,
you know what girls liked it?
They like what smells like the inside of a cage.
That's what they like.
They like would older Musk.
Yeah.
That's just been running through a forest trying to catch them and fuck them.
That's when he said that that's the smell they liked.
You know,
glade like the kitchen,
glade shit.
They have this new kind that smells Musky.
It's most like a Persian nightclub.
And so now,
uh,
the other day my friend sprayed it in my house and now my,
it doesn't smell like Lysol.
It smells like Persian nightclub and it's made by the glade company.
It's like axe body spray,
Lysol.
It's,
oh,
that's awful.
Here is like some bachelors scent.
Yeah,
that's a really,
yeah.
It's like,
it's like a Cologne for,
what's it called?
What do they call it?
It's called
kitchen sensations or something stupid like,
Oh,
you just spit off.
It's like a poor Noman.
Yeah,
it just sensation.
Sounds like porno.
It's good.
It's fucking portal.
Could you imagine if that was some fucking CIA shit?
If they came out with some stuff that made people fuck like mad dogs and it was
one of those plugins they started wall,
like they just wanted to do some population studies.
So if they can just up the population in neighborhood,
so they start selling in a very controlled market like Cleveland or some shit.
They start selling these little glade air fresheners.
Wicked cheap.
Yes.
Start giving them away.
You know,
Oh,
you buy a fucking a Futon,
you get a free glade,
you know,
hard on air freshener.
Start sticking these things in the wall and people will just start going crazy.
Just fucking the shit out of each other.
The koolaid hard on,
listen man.
They could have something like that that affects your behavior.
You know when they were,
when the Iraq war first star jumped off,
they were seriously considered trying to figure out how to make a gay bomb.
They were trying to figure out a way to drop something on these guys that would
be like some sort of ecstasy concoction that would just make them super horny
and loving each other and started hugging any,
we'd kill morale and they would just,
their army would just fall apart.
That's how devious the scientists we have working for us are all got to blow
this pop.
Now.
This is over.
This fucking chose over five oh seven February 4th Mandalay Bay theater.
Buy Your tickets,
bitches.
They're going quickly.
Sussman Sussman probably calling me right now.
God Damn it is it.
It ain't me today.
18 tickets.
Dummies.
Bullshit.
I don't like voicemail though.
That's the problem.
So I don't shut this.
Hey,
come to my show.
Sunday I Sal's comedy club on Melrose.
I'm having open,
Mike is handling six o'clock
six starts at six eight ways.
I could come Sunday,
Sunday.
It starts at six o'clock with guns and go to like whenever.
That's all.
Well and good,
but this is what you know in bitches.
Need to know.
February 4th Mandalay Bay theater.
Joe Coco Diaz,
Joe Rogan,
Ari red band confirmed dirty terrorists.
Isn't a terrorist.
They what they say,
he'll be happy to know.
You're going Brian.
Ari Shapiro.
S h o f,
F,
I r on Twitter.
Um,
Brian Red band will be going well.
The film had bench.
Some shit's going down.
February four,
Mandalay Bay theater.
We've got to Joe rogan.net.
You could buy the tickets.
It's available there.
I know what else is available.
You get a discount on the fleshlight baby.
Oh Shit son,
if you think beaten off as good,
oh,
you don't know what you're missing,
ladies and gentlemen,
what I a CD subject to be talking about?
Where's my blow up?
The outside world?
You far?
Could you get it?
Yeah.
I'm waiting for you to just,
I don't want to hear this man.
I don't want hear whatever you're playing.
What is that?
Oh,
you guys moe theme song.
okay.
I thought it was real metal.
I love you guys.
Merry Christmas.
We love each and every one of your bitches.
Even the people that like metal.
We love.
Uh,
I love heavy metal.
I love Warburton.
Cocksuckers we love the people that love everything.
With a Facebook check yourself before you wreck yourself.
You know the word,
you know the rest of the fucking song.
You can't take a joke.
Get on the subway.
I was bad at via help.
Cock suck as I lay black,
cause that's the most important thing.
20 bullet hit me up with a video from Austin is almost completed.
Brian,
how many more days?
Think?
Ah,
not long.
I just got a little bit too involved editing some music and digital end of it
now.
Just taken too long.
So how many days?
Three.
Four yet Monday.
Not that long.
Monday let's of on Monday.
Let's make it a Monday.
28 for Austin.
Next week is a new year's UFC in the in Vegas.
Holla at your boy.
Um,
Mandalay bay again.
February 4th.
Buy Tickets online and get him on Joe rogan.net and a that's it.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click the link.
Get 15% off tonight.
Tomorrow night.
John Lovitz combined CME Saint Mary Kay Philippe can shows and Philippe spas a
winning last comic standing and Jon Lovitz,
Eddie Edwards,
San Juan.
The Filipino wall going to be down at today.
John Lovitz club is universal city universal.
Seven o'clock tonight and tomorrow in the city.
Walk upstairs.
It's a ass place.
And Brian's at South Hills on Melrose on Sunday and I'll be there with Brian
to thank everybody for tuning in.
Stay black,
love.
Appreciate it.
Love you bitches by it.
I never know how to end these things.
What is it ended?
I never know how to end this thing.
Oh,
we're not done it.
Why you don't want to end it?
Because I want to hear the song.
All right,
goodbye.
I didn't know Don India.
I'm going to.
You got gotta keep this going first.
Hold on.
Jodi.
Jodi as needs to hear bill up the outside world play and blow up the outside
world.
What's up man?
That's it folks.
Generally shut up.
I love you.